Struggle,
all right,
ladies and gentlemen would live the
presidents now blind spend staring at
the sun all day trying to see the
eclipse.
There's photos of it.
Mike Baker help us out.
What?
What are we doing,
man?
Well,
Dahlia,
that's probably,
again,
it's,
it's an indication that they don't have
a lot of discipline in that
Communications Department of the White
House.
No one got him the message,
don't Sir Sir.
Don't.
Don't look at the sun.
Not only that,
definitely don't look at the sun while
people are looking at you,
Jesus Christ,
the whole world is going to mock you.
Don't you know that everybody knows is
since they were a kid,
right?
Even even if you've never been involved
in an eclipse,
every kid knows.
Don't look at the sun.
It's the one thing that every child
learned somehow.
You know,
when I tried to do that,
I'm a fucking idiot.
I took a two dark sunglasses.
I put them on top of each other.
That'll where I put one pair and then I
put another layer over.
It doesn't work folks.
It looks good.
It does look good,
but I only looked for a second and I
went,
oh,
okay,
this doesn't work,
but you know where I could look at it.
I can look at it through my pool,
like the reflection.
Oh sure.
You'll see the eclipse,
but it never really got fully dark here.
No,
we're too low.
Yeah,
we,
I just came down from,
from Idaho.
I was up there in the mountains over the
past few days and it was just,
it did just hippies coming in from left
and right.
Tire state just overrun with the hippies
and they're,
I mean their parking and people's,
you know,
ranches,
they just driving up on fields that have
just been planted there just like they
don't even think.
And so they.
But they kept my.
Yeah,
you know,
hey God bless him.
I don't know that I was intellectually
curious enough to really worry about the
eclipse.
There's a balance in.
You know what?
I think a lot of intellectual curiosity
is great and a lot of hippie values are
great,
but then you go too far into the hippie
retard gene pool and you get these dopey
hippies that are hippies that know
they're the worst kind of hippies,
hippies that don't really want to do any
work,
but they want universal basic income.
They want all of these.
These one percenters,
they have plenty of money so that no one
should have to work ever.
They just passed it.
They passed a tax up in Seattle.
It's gonna probably going to get struck
down,
but it basically,
it was up in Seattle,
will got blessed them up there.
They they've decided that they're going
to go against the state charter,
which says you can't have a attacks,
right?
An income tax,
and they've gone ahead and done it for
the.
I think it's for the top two percent.
The only tax that tax.
The tax people are doing something right
because you know,
you gotta make this thing more
equitable.
That's hilarious.
That's really funny.
Well,
what's interesting is that's the whole
reason why a lot of companies like
Amazon and Microsoft is the reason why
they've located to Seattle.
You fucking stomachs and they're going
to pull out and then you wouldn't have
any jobs and then you'll be poor.
Somebody is going to pay for that.
Yeah.
We came from,
we moved out from fairfield county,
from New Canaan,
Connecticut when we moved out to Idaho,
which was the world's greatest movie of
all.
Connecticut.
Sucks.
I say it over and over again and.
But yeah,
I mean,
but they know it.
You better get Noah and then people,
but you live in a lucky spot and.
And they,
they,
their plan,
the,
the plan of the governor and the rest of
the crew there is when you need more
money tax,
fairfield county where I,
which is home to new Canaan and
Greenwich and Darien and Stanford.
The people that work in the city or the
people that are working in finance and
now what they've,
what they've had over the past three,
four years.
Ever since the governor's been running
the shop is people moving out.
I mean,
every GE moved out of General Electric,
the entire operation with General
Electric said went to the state and
said,
I know people will think of why are we
talking about this?
But they went to the State House and
they said,
you can't keep doing this.
You can't keep jacking it up on us to
pay for everything.
We're happy to pay and we are apparent,
our fair share.
But so they did that in general.
Like you said,
we're going to move.
The state didn't believe him.
They've all relocated to Boston.
Um,
they've got,
uh,
who else is moving to Aetna?
I think the,
uh,
the large insurance company,
you know,
now Connecticut's known as sort of the
insurance capital,
right?
They're leaving hedge funds,
private equity groups moving down to
Florida.
And again,
great pay your fair share,
but at a certain point
everybody's got to contribute something.
You can't just say that's what you're
gonna do.
And I'm not in the one percent.
I wish I was.
It used to be when you were a kid,
you wanted to be rich right now,
you know,
I don't know what people want.
They want to be in the middle.
You want to be comfortable.
That's where you want to be comfortable.
I,
I don't know,
I always thought it'd be pretty cool to
be wealthy and all and,
and I think I'd be pretty good at it.
My friend Brian Cowen said it best once
and it stuck with me forever.
He said,
you know what you want to be.
You want to be to the point where you
don't have to worry about your bills and
you can go to a restaurant and not worry
about what you order.
He goes,
everything other than that,
it's bullshit.
Yeah.
Because everybody,
you know,
and that's,
that's a good point I guess because
that's,
you take that stress out of your life
and then I get,
well I guess you're gonna worry about
it.
So people find it.
Yes.
Just stress and stress,
right?
I mean like look at these assholes that
buy these $500,000,000 yachts.
It's like they just realized like,
oh,
enough problems in my life.
I need to buy a fucking floating city.
And then I got,
I got to hire a crew of 100 to hate me,
talk shit about me.
Every time I turned my back they,
I want to fuck my wife,
dammit.
I'm going to get in line.
Bosens made finished.
Compost is made.
I know what I came up with.
Bows.
And is that a real thing?
I think it is.
Yeah.
I think there was such thing as a
[inaudible] made this always like this
ebb and flow,
right?
I mean the people that have accumulated
too much wealth,
especially when it comes to like hedge
fund people and finance people.
It's like,
what are you actually doing?
Right?
And you're using that money to influence
policy and that policy allows you to
extract more money from the system and
it gets real slippery because
occasionally you guys fuck up and it
crashes the whole economy.
Right?
Like that kind of money is like really
creepy.
But when you're talking about someone
who's developed a legitimate product,
they sell it and they're successful,
they work hard.
They made something.
Some does business.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The hiring people there,
you know there's a,
there's a house for sale up in the
Hamptons,
now there's a house for $175.
Million Dollars.
It seems logical.
Yeah.
One hundred and $75,000,000.
But you know what?
It's on the beach.
So it's,
it's got waterfront to it.
So I guess that explains the Price Tag.
But here's the thing about that water
fund.
Anybody can walk in front of your house.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's a huge problem in Malibu.
There's this,
a couple of other I'm friends with and
their sons surf and they live in Malibu.
They have a house in Malibu and they
were surfing in the water in front of
this house.
This guy comes out and yells and screams
at him,
you know,
get the fuck off the beach because you
know,
a $10,000,000 house right there on the
beach.
And they're like,
what are you talking about?
Like we live right over there.
You piece of shit.
And like not only that,
anybody can be on this beach.
This is the ocean.
You can't,
you don't own the private beach signs up
and ate it and for the most part that's
true.
Up and the Hamilton,
I think this actually has some private
beach frontage,
which again,
so $175 million seems somewhat
reasonable.
Hampton's most expensive home.
There it is right there.
One hundred and $75.
Got a lake,
a.
he's got a lake and then further past
the leg.
Wow.
They all have lakes.
What is that?
Is that freshwater or brackish water?
That must be brackish water,
right?
I guess.
I guess a pretty bad ass don't have fish
in your front yard like that.
I wonder if the kitchen appliances
convey how big is this house?
Is that.
Wait a minute.
That overhead view was the entire
property baller.
You know what though?
But look at that picture though.
Does that look like $175?
Million dollars in your mind when you
think the whole fucking thing.
She'd be plated in gold.
Forty two acres.
Wow.
Okay.
There you go.
That's what,
that's what it is.
Oh,
the Ford family.
Oh Ah.
Oh.
Well the car company.
So hashtag balling on Mustang if you
get,
I think you're right,
if you get to that point where you can
entertain the idea of maybe I'll put 10
percent down and then I'll take the rest
of the mortgage.
Um,
then yeah,
you've probably got too much money.
He reminds me of that scene in the big
Lebowski when you meet the big Lebowski
and he's in the wheelchair and his
wife's off from the suck dude's Dick for
a thousand bucks.
You know,
it's like,
that's the kind of shit that happens.
You get a trophy wife,
you buy yourself a mansion and your days
are just filled with stress is such a
great movie.
It's a great movie.
God,
I used to use that movie to judge
whether or not I enjoyed people's
opinions.
Really.
Tell me anything about the big Lebowski.
Okay.
I talked to a lot of people.
They said I couldn't make it through the
first hour and I'm thinking,
how do you not?
How do you not find this funny?
Gees,
I let my kids watch it.
The admittedly the two youngest walked
away,
but the older one,
he,
you know.
So anyway,
uh,
yeah,
I've taken him fishing tomorrow morning
off to Alaska in the morning.
Oh,
salmon or halibut?
Salmon.
The Salmon.
I aren't uh,
you know,
interested in us.
We'll go after some.
Halibut is a silver salmon season right
now.
Right.
Okay.
So you're on the open water.
So when you guys go,
well,
we'll go.
Yeah,
we'll go up to catch can a,
which is really interesting place by
itself.
And then we've got to take a plane out
of there about,
uh,
about 45 minutes outside of that to a
little place called [inaudible] Bay and
they have a really good operation up
there and he spent a lot of time and to
be honest with you,
if the,
if the fish aren't biting,
then we just go hiking.
I'm going to take my boy will be a first
time for him to go up there and it's
going to be great.
It's got.
But I've just now emptied the freezer of
a salmon and halibut and rock fish from
the last trip.
So it's time to stock up again,
but it's just a great time of year.
Isn't that a great thing?
To have fish that you caught in your
freezer,
they can go back to the,
you know,
it was only like an hour old by the time
you threw it on the ice.
It's,
it's fantastic.
And so if and,
and just also just getting up there,
if people have been up to Alaska to get
up there and see it before it melts.
I said that I think it's good.
It'll be fine.
Are you worried about it?
Um,
you know what?
Not in the sense that Oh my God,
if I,
if I don't quit driving my wagon here,
the glaciers are going to all melt away.
I,
you know,
I'm sure we have some impact and it's
like everything else,
right?
The truth is in the middle somewhere,
So I'm sure we should all do our part,
but do I think we're all gonna you know,
the polar bears are dying off tomorrow.
I know,
but well there's definitely somebody
with their ideas.
Yeah.
There's definitely some issues with
polar bears in areas that have less ice,
but apparently the polar bear
population.
This is something that I've read about
Canada,
at least in Canada,
the polar bear population is higher than
it's been in years.
Now there's a,
there's not a shortage of polar bears,
but if you go over there to like they
have hunts for polar bears,
like they pay people to take them on
polar bear hunts,
but then you can't bring the polar bear
back to the United States so you can
keep it in Canada.
You can like if you come from Europe and
you want to hunt a polar bear,
you can.
It's all very.
Well.
You mentioned trying to pack a polar
bear back into the states to know.
I just shot that.
You can see what the reaction would be
a.
I think it's yeah,
everybody should do their part,
right?
There's no doubt about that.
You know,
don't be a Douche and.
But the problem is in part it's like
both sides,
they latch onto one piece of
information.
Right?
So like what you just said,
you know,
the polar bear population to grow so
that once I will latch onto and say,
see,
there's no such thing as climate change
and the other side we'll find one piece
of it and they'll latch onto that and
then,
okay.
And like I said,
I,
I'm a big believer that somewhere in the
middle is where most of the truth sets,
but I'm sure there's definitely polar
bear problems higher north,
right in the ice caps.
And I mean I've seen some,
some issues where they're talking about
polar bear starving up there and the
lack of ice contributing to starvation
deaths.
And yeah,
so I,
but it's,
it's,
uh,
regardless,
I'm looking forward to the last guy.
I think regardless of what the hell
happened to the polar bears,
I'm going to have a good trip.
Um,
but I think it's,
it's a beautiful state.
People should get up there if they
haven't been up there.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
It's one of the rare places that you
could go to in America that is like real
wilderness and that is a really wild
place.
And,
and you can get.
Yeah,
exactly.
And it doesn't take,
it doesn't take much to get up there and
money I just made,
it doesn't,
it's not the effort that people,
I think sometimes imagine it to be
right.
And uh,
yeah,
so it's,
it's a,
it's a great trip.
Kids really looking forward to it and
it's weird that it's the United States,
isn't it?
When you look at the map.
Yeah.
You think about how it was put together.
That's a fascinating story.
I,
for what?
That's worth people.
That's another good interesting read is
how we cobbled this country together and
sort of some of it was just incredible
genius on the part of some folks.
Some of it was serendipity,
some of it was,
you know,
short sighted vision on the part of the
Russians or the French or oh they fucked
up.
But with Alaska the Russians fucked up.
Yeah.
What did they give that to us for like
50 bucks?
It wasn't much money.
It wasn't much.
No,
I guess we got our money's worth out of
that by now.
But uh,
anyway,
so yeah,
we'll do that.
And,
and,
uh,
and I planned this trip.
Of course their school starts tomorrow.
They're there,
all three of them are in elementary
school,
so their school starts tomorrow and uh,
and I gave my kid that option.
I said,
do you want to,
you know,
he starts in fifth grade.
I said,
do you,
do you want to stay here so you don't
miss the first few days at school?
And he looked at me like,
what are you crazy exactly an idiot.
I mean,
that's how.
But it's what his eyes said.
He didn't say that.
How old is he?
He's just turned 10.
He's got to learn more in the woods.
Absolutely.
For a couple of days.
Yeah.
Have a good time.
Have a wonderful experience.
Because of course the grizzlies are out
looking for the salmon.
I mean,
and it's a,
it's just fantastic.
That's the safest time to be around
them.
So when their salmon out,
yeah,
they're just fat and happy there and
they don't bother you.
And so,
uh,
you know,
if something happens to my 10 year old
and my wife said it's going to be my
fault,
that's on my head and I can't blame her.
That would,
that would be true.
But do you pack when you're out there,
you packing the side arm?
Um,
no,
no we don't because we're,
when we go up there and we're going up
with uh,
what,
uh,
about a dozen other guys and they pan,
they deal with the lodge does stay in
the small little sort of.
It's not,
I,
you know,
I say launch.
It's a wonderful place.
Family owned.
It's not a fancy place at all,
but it's a great little spot and they do
a great job.
The guides are fantastic.
So,
um,
we'll have a good time.
But yeah,
we don't,
we don't take anything with us.
I mean it's just.
Yeah,
no,
that makes sense.
As long as the people up there,
I mean,
you probably won't need anything as long
as the bears have fish.
They really have.
No.
There's an area that we've shown this
video before of this enormous grizzly
that gets right next to this guy who's
sitting there photographing these bears,
eating a fish out of the river,
and the bear literally couldn't give a
fuck.
He just looks at him and just sort of
wanders off and there's actually a
statistic that no one has ever died in
this area.
No,
no person has ever been attacked or
killed in this one area just because
it's just overrun with.so preoccupied
this time of year.
But it's also,
you know,
you talk about how things change around
the planet and the salmon runs are
really being impacted right now by a
variety of reasons.
You know,
it's not just one thing,
but.
So anyway.
Uh,
but that'll be,
that'll be good.
And I know that everybody was really
keen to hear about my upcoming trip.
So,
you know,
I mean,
it is interesting to hear people's take
on the climate issue because there's
hard left and hard,
right?
Hard,
right is a,
it's a cycle.
It's always happened this way and
you're,
you're impeding business.
Hard left is we're all going to die and
then Miami's going to drown.
I mean,
uh,
an Al Gore had dirty predicted in that
movie an inconvenient truth that we were
going to be covered in water in 2014,
2014.
They were predicting that the ocean
levels are going to rise the point where
we're going to have to start evacuating
some of the coastal cities.
And he missed that one just by a little
bit,
but yeah.
Yeah.
But baby came out with another movie.
12 people saw an inconvenient truth and
um,
nobody,
nobody.
I just watched it,
I don't think.
But it's,
you see bill Nye when he was on Tucker
Carlson's show.
No,
it was very interesting.
It was very interesting.
Cause I'm bill Nye who is not really a
scientist.
What is he?
Is He,
uh,
he's just an engineer's near the base to
have to be smart,
but you know,
he calls himself Bill Nye the science
guy.
He's bothered by the way,
as an undergraduate degree,
sunny even a phd I want to be.
And they were uh,
they were talking about climate change.
And Tucker Carlson said,
I'm willing to absolutely believe that
people have an impact on climate change.
He goes,
but can you tell me how much?
And then Bill Nye kind of got flustered
and you know,
he,
he got like little confrontational
defensive.
It's really kind of interesting because
Tucker kept pestering him like,
we're talking about science.
So I would like you to tell me how much
of an impact have people had.
What are the numbers?
Is it a narrow range?
Because you give me a narrow range.
It's just what he does is he publicizes
science for his own personal benefit.
Is that terrible show on Netflix.
Bill Nye saves the world,
bitch,
you're not saving shit then.
Okay.
You can't call your shell.
Bill Nye saves the world.
You're not saving the world with this
crazy goddamn song about gender.
And he has,
oh my God.
Did you see that?
That was,
that was stunning.
Who The fuck greenlit dad?
Like I love Netflix,
but hey,
a little quality controls.
Not a bad thing.
Just have somebody on set to go hope.
What we'll say is this like this,
like a sensor,
like in the old,
but that movie,
good morning,
Vietnam,
you know somebody that sits there and
reads through his material before he
does it and I saw that.
Not that you know it clearly they don't
have anybody who has to approve as
content.
That shows you where his mindset that
he's willing to say yes to that.
That's someone who wants to acquiesce
with no uncertain terms to the left.
Yeah.
Like he just wants to.
Every meanwhile he had a film out of a
movie or a television show out years ago
where he was describing gender and it
was basically saying there's genders and
it's about x and y chromosome,
which is what everybody's been told in
science and biology class.
Then he has this show just a few years
later where thou,
the tide has turned politically where
this is such a weird subject about
gender and sexual identity and gender
identity and so he's got these songs
about,
you know,
like what that lady singing that song
like,
Hey,
this is fucking terrible.
Like what all you're doing.
It's just like the same thing as
president trump staring at the sun.
Yeah.
All you're doing is setting yourself up
for rootless criticism.
That's going to diminish any potential
legitimate point that you actually have.
But I will say this,
I don't think he really got pilloried
for it.
Right?
I mean nobody really.
Um,
I mean there was some,
some mine.
Yeah.
I think some people make fun of them,
but I think Bill Knight for the most
part,
he knows it.
It's a very comfortable place for him to
do.
Or for a lot of people,
if they say,
look,
I just want to get the adulation of the
left,
the far left and then fine.
I mean that's what you want to do,
do it.
But you see people that kind of shift
their position and are happy to be there
because they know they're going to be
coddled.
And I.
So I,
I get why he does it because it's a base
of,
of uh,
it's an audience that he knows is gonna
stick with them as long as he says the
right things.
And apparently he doesn't really give a
shit about science.
So he's happy to say anything.
Well,
I think he does give a shit about
science.
He gives a shit more about people liking
him and fitting in with this crowd of
people.
There's a weird thing that's going on in
science and there's nothing like science
is fantastic.
It's critical for our civilization.
I'm not a science criticizer,
but there's a weird thing about people
that are a part of science where their
own egos and their own need for positive
affirmation sort of supersede any
critical thinking.
So there's certain subjects that cannot
be discussed.
There's certain things that like,
they're,
they're almost like,
it's almost like science,
religion,
you know.
So there's certain subjects that are,
aren't even open to scrutiny.
Well I think that's right.
And I think part of it is,
is also we have gotten to a point where
you can't,
and I don't know how you walk it back,
but you can't have conflicting ideas in
the same statement or the same sentence
and an idea.
Things conflict all the time.
Right.
And you can have a truths that collide
with each other and don't.
I don't necessarily make sense.
So.
But it seems as if now everything has to
be an absolute and whether it's climate
change,
so you can't say,
you know,
if you,
if you just have this middle of the
road,
you know,
discussion where you're saying,
well look,
of course,
you know,
humans I'm sure have some impact.
I don't know what that is.
And then,
and you know,
this is a problem,
then we do have to do our part and we do
have to work to,
to try to be the best we can be.
But that's not good enough.
You've got to,
you've got to be a sort of totalitarian
about the whole issue.
And it's not just that it's,
it's any argument,
it just seems as if,
and it's not just a millennial,
so I'm not wanting to,
to beat on,
you know,
the young kids or the generation of
whatever we want to call them nowadays
because I know a lot of good kids that
are out there that are working hard or
they're in the military and it's a
fantastic group of folks.
So I think we're just fine in that
regard.
But there does seem to be something
about each successive generation and
we've gotten to a point where people
have a hard time processing this
dissenting opinion idea and that starts
to shut down debate and it starts to
shut down the idea that you can have a
discussion about science,
where you have,
you know,
these conflicting ideas and how do you,
how do you resolve them?
That used to be the whole concept about
sciences to test theories and with
little works and anyway,
what do I think?
It's because we're attaching egos and
personalities and virtue signaling to
the actual hard data itself,
but here's,
here's the thing that we should all be
concerned with.
Pollution.
We should all be concerned with human
waste.
We should all be concerned with the
damage that we're doing to our water,
the damage that we're doing to the
environment,
the.
There's a host of different things that
human beings are involved in that are
creating irreparable harm to the
environment.
We should absolutely be concerned with
that,
but what's weird is that you hardly ever
hear about that.
You hardly ever hear about doing
something to curb the plastic in the
ocean and doing something to eliminate
that.
Some of the sewage waste that goes into
the ocean doing the,
oh,
there's a ton of different things that
we're doing that are huge issues,
but instead you hear about climate
change and it becomes this ideological
left versus right battle,
which is very weird to me.
And I understand that climate change is
a real issue and if the ocean water
continues to rise,
coastal cities really are fucked and if
the temperature does rise,
we really might have to migrate to more
better climates.
But there's a lot of other shit going on
that seems to get ignored during this
process.
Just,
I mean,
I,
you know,
I'm old enough to remember when a
plastics that was an issue,
right?
Plastic bags or,
or um,
you know,
keeping the oceans clean or you know,
don't be a little bug.
I mean,
was,
it was more of a,
it was things that you could accomplish,
right?
It was things that you could do with the
community.
Could do.
So you would have these community drive
to pick up trash or to not use plastic
bags or to whatever it is,
and it was stuff that you could do and
you could see some results and it felt
good about it.
And you know,
who knows,
maybe we've gone past that now.
And so now,
uh,
that's not good enough because,
you know,
now we've got to save the planet.
Will you save the planet these little
steps at a time,
right?
If every,
every community says,
well,
you know,
I'm sorry I can't do anything about the
polar bears,
so fuck it.
I'm just going to worry about myself.
But if you,
if you bring it back down to those
little things like you would,
you know,
maybe implying that I think we're better
off.
Right?
And eventually you,
you do make a difference.
But if all you do is talk about climate
change and save the planet,
people just get overwhelmed.
It's like a lot of other things in life
and you're just thinking,
fuck it.
I'm just gonna focus on other shit.
It was just so strange to
climate change.
It's become this weird ideological
debate between the left and the right,
and is it when it comes to plastic,
there's a solution that's been around
for years for plastic.
There's biodegradable hemp plastic.
It's existed for a long time.
If they just legalized hemp farming
nationwide,
federally let people grow hemp in mass
quantities.
You could turn that into plastic.
You would never have to worry about
water bottles again.
You'd never have to worry about garbage
bags.
He would never have to worry about
anything because it's all be plant based
plastic,
which is real biodegradable.
You put it in the ground,
it becomes dirt.
So what's the.
What's the,
what's the holdup?
Well,
federally hemp has been legal since the
19 thirties.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
I mean,
and all of that goes back to William
Randolph hearst conning people into
making it illegal so we didn't have to
switch over his paper mills from wood
son of a bitch.
That son of a bitch.
Yeah,
hearst.
That's right.
I forgot he's the guy to do that.
Yeah.
Wow.
Amazing.
Him and Harry Anslinger and you know,
what they did is they organized an
actual campaign against Hamp as a
commodity by demonizing this thing that
they called marijuana,
which didn't even,
it wasn't even the name of cannabis at
the time that marijuana was a name for a
wild Mexican tobacco.
They applied that name to cannabis to
say that there's this new drug that's
making Mexicans and blacks rape white
women and they,
you know,
he was a piece of Shit that William
Randolph hearst and he printed all these
articles and his papers and they made
reefer madness and all that stuff.
All those movies that they made back in
the day.
Have you ever seen?
Oh,
it's wonderful.
It's great.
It makes me want to get high.
And then,
uh,
and then of course they made citizen
Kane and that turned her into a
household name and uh,
you know,
relatively benign character,
you,
Orson Welles,
I wonder what he did to Orson Welles.
He must have fucked with them a little
bit,
don't you think?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Interesting.
When we did that movie come out,
citizen Kane came out in a long time.
You know,
people are like,
why are they talking?
I want to say it was the fifties.
Oh,
it was earlier than that I think was 19,
19,
41.
Forty one.
Oh,
Rko pictures.
Still to this day,
it's an airplane.
I couldn't believe I was.
I was on an airplane not too long ago
when I was looking to the movies
together.
Am I going to watch anything or am I get
up?
And Susan Cain was on.
I couldn't put,
which was strange.
It was right there in the middle of all
these typical marvel and DC comics
movies that you would expect on a plane.
That's odd.
So I started watching it and the,
uh,
the dude next to me in the seat next to
me kind of starts,
you can tell when someone's watching
your screen over there finally
attachment of the show.
And he says,
what are you watching?
And he was you.
He was probably a couple of years
younger than me,
but not much.
And I said,
I watch citizen Kane.
Never heard of it.
Never,
never heard of it.
I wish,
I guess no big deal.
Fine.
But you know,
Jerry Lewis died and people are probably
saying,
who's that?
He's like,
probably one of those dudes at the gym.
It talks too much.
He's one of those guys that comes up to
you while you're benching.
I'm gonna.
Ask a question,
am I doing this right?
Or even where I still go,
you should drop your shoulder a little
bit with those fucking guys because what
you'll do is you'll stress that and then
that'll be better for you and you'll.
Okay.
Thank you.
Love those guys.
They use big words.
Try to convince you they know what
they're talking about.
So speaking of a citizen Kane and Orson
Welles and conspiracies,
last night I rewatched the episode of
Geraldo Rivera is good night America
when they introduced the Zapruder
because you know,
Dick Gregory just died.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They introduced this approved or film to
the American public,
uh,
13 years or 12 years,
12 years after Kennedy's assassination.
And uh,
then I went and read that paper,
the articles.
That was the printed a couple of weeks
ago that,
uh,
you even tweeted about it,
about the CIA questioning the official
story of the JFK assassination.
Yeah.
That was interesting,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
So the CIA guy,
what do you think about that?
Well,
first of all,
that's approved of film.
That's the most watched piece of film in
history of film has a really,
which is really interesting.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
it was interesting that the,
you know,
as typical with a lot of these things
that the headline doesn't necessarily
actually match once you get into the
body of the story,
but the idea being that the agency
had some concerns over
the idea that perhaps a Cuba was behind
the assassination was the Russians to
some degree or some more likely in a
combination of the two.
Um,
look,
I think,
you know,
I do,
I think that,
uh,
that,
he could have taken that shot.
Yeah,
it was,
it was.
Yeah,
it was not.
I said I've been up in that book
depository from that point of view,
that vantage point.
We did a story on the,
on the,
uh,
the whole,
issue that conspiracy theory and what
could have happened.
Then we tried to find some new witnesses
and,
you know,
could he have made that shot?
Yeah.
That was,
that was,
it was a straightforward,
you know,
effort was someone who had some
training.
He was,
you know,
he wasn't the world's best shot,
but he had sufficient training to make
that shot.
No,
that's separate from
his motivations and any potential
support that he may have gotten a during
the course of that.
And,
you know,
I think that he,
in his mind,
he,
he genuinely felt that this was going to
get him into the revolution,
right.
That this was going to.
It had a very unhappy experience in
Russia when he was over there living,
came back,
um,
saw what was happening in Cuba,
desperately wanted to be part of that,
uh,
took an unexplained trip down to Mexico.
Uh,
which could well have been in an effort
to find somebody who could support his,
his desire to,
to take some sort of action whether he
had formed in his mind that's what he
was going to do at the time or not.
So,
you know,
is there a still a possibility that,
um,
the Cubans,
which they're the Intel service there
would have had to file on him.
I mean,
he was a very,
very well known quantity,
obviously by that time,
for the Russians.
The Russians
are solely responsible for training up
the Cuban Intel service.
So there's a massive file on him and
they knew who they were dealing with.
They knew his weaknesses,
they knew his,
um,
they knew his motivations,
they knew what to do in terms of trying
to get leverageable,
you know,
uh,
information on him.
So I think that
the jury's still out.
I'm not,
and I'm not a conspiracy guy,
but I think there's enough there that
says,
you know,
yes,
it's Kinda like what we're talking about
climate change.
I believe this,
but this also could be true.
I think he could have taken that shot
for sure.
Uh,
and,
and succeeded,
I think it's also possible that he may
have had the encouragement of,
in particular the Cuban Intel service
through the Russians because at that
time in particular they didn't do
anything.
The Cubans didn't do anything without
the Russians support blessings and
direction.
So that is entirely possible.
Um,
do I think that there were a variety of
other things at play,
you know,
was,
did they help him get the,
the,
uh,
the weapon?
Did they,
I mean,
you know,
was her actual logistical support in
there?
I don't know.
I don't think so,
but that'd be on maybe.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a fascinating thing.
And you know,
again,
nobody wants to think that something
that uh,
impactful could have been just one guy
who,
you know,
had a dream about being a hero of the
revolution.
And I think they just,
it's,
it's such an awful thing to think about.
You want something bigger,
you want something more behind it.
And it's,
it's,
I will say the one thing that I think
there was something else too was the
Mlk,
Martin Luther King assassination.
Well,
let's get to that for sure,
but here's the thing about the,
the Lee Harvey Oswald assassination,
you know,
a lot of people think that there was
people in the grassy knoll and that they
shot at the president and there was more
than one shooter.
That's possible too.
And here's the other problem with people
saying that Oswald could have never made
that shot.
Of course he could have 100 percent he
could have.
Is it likely?
Listen,
people throw three point shots that have
no fucking business on a basketball
court and they hit nothing but net.
It happens all the time.
It doesn't mean it's not likely that a
guy could get off three shots that
quick,
but it is possible.
There was more time in there than they
originally thought.
There been.
There's some misinformation out there
about how condensed that timeframe was.
And now after they've,
you know,
research has seemed to have a fairly.
Well at that timeframe extended a little
bit,
but he had more importantly he had.
He worked up there.
So he had the opportunity to see that
site.
Right?
So he was like,
he was sitting in a blind weight and
then figuring out what am I going to be
doing here,
and that's a tremendous advantage and
clear daylight targets moving right in
line with you.
There's no wind.
Not only that,
it's not that far shot.
No,
it's not.
It's not like everybody thinks it's like
a half mile away or something like that.
I mean how far was it?
It was 150 yards or something like that
to
go back and find that.
But I've.
But I've stood on that
spot where the limo was at the site and
I stood up there and that down and it's
not that far.
And it's a total makeup was shot on a
deer.
Yeah.
I'll give you.
We're going to shoot a deer with a
rifle.
You'd be like,
Oh yeah,
that's definitely my effective range.
No,
there was no how far it would go.
Two hundred and 60.
Five feet.
Eighty one meters.
That ain't shit.
That's a bowshot yeah.
You could shoot an animal with a bow
from 80 meters if you're really good and
there's no wind.
So that's a really close shot.
So the idea that he couldn't make that
shot,
he's a bad shot.
That is so fucking stupid.
He absolutely could make that shot and
that will look that he could make that
shot from 81 meters.
That's nothing.
We looked at the grassy knoll issue.
We looked at the end of that.
What,
what the,
the train yard engineer,
um,
reported seeing,
with a sort of a puff of smoke that he
thought he saw over by the fence line.
And,
and we're looking at like,
yeah,
you could,
you know,
from that position,
they opened that place up and we were
able to go back up there and you could
see it.
We ran a couple of tests and fired off a
few shots and that's always fun if you
want to have,
I've got a good time to take a rifle to
dealey plaza and fire off a few shots
without the tourist knowing what the
hell is happening.
And The Dallas police by the way,
were tremendous during the course of
that.
But,
um,
when did you guys do this?
We did this a while back for a show
called American declassified,
which isn't running anymore,
um,
but it was on a,
on the travel channel.
Jesse Ventura did that.
He went up there and with a mandolin
incur carcanos same rifle.
And I was looking for a possible shock.
No one could make the shock camp.
I love Jesse.
I think he's awesome.
But you to be conspiracy
significantly on that side to the point
where,
you know,
that's he's leaning always toward the
conspiracy.
Yeah.
Would you want to do is you want to do
every investigation,
and I know this company that I've got,
we,
we do a lot of investigations and you've
got a bill just like with a homicide
case or anything else.
You've got to build it on stable ground,
right?
So you have to start from,
you know,
the very basics because if you start
building ideas and investigative
inquiries on something that's not sturdy
underneath it,
you know,
not based on evidence and fact then you
got a problem.
The whole thing becomes suspect and
usually comes toppling down.
So,
you know,
I,
you got to keep an open mind about all
these things and I think it's important.
Um,
right now people are like,
Oh,
well I'm sure that agency,
the CIA was involved.
So I'm a terrible source of information.
I've,
I've heard that before.
So you can't talk credibly about this
because you know,
the CIA was involved in,
I think he is a thing of the CIA was
involved.
It's not you,
you weren't there.
And I was 62 last time I checked.
I was not there in 1962 and a.
and also I will tell you this much.
Or was it 63?
It was 60 slash six slash 63.
If the age,
if the agency had been involved.
This is the honest to God's truth.
There's no way that secret is still
kept.
People can't keep their Yap shut.
They can't.
And secrets have a way of coming out and
certainly a lot quicker now than they
used to.
So now.
But I did
the secrets then.
I mean we're talking about so long ago
how much talking to them more than 50
years ago.
Like get out.
It's like the DB cooper issue,
my biggest reason for believing db
cooper died and his chute is hanging off
a tree and that's a vast wilderness up
there.
Yeah.
Is,
is that people just,
they can't help themselves at some point
people talk or somebody talks somebody
associated with or somebody nearby or
somebody involved or somebody on their
deathbed or somebody says something they
shouldn't have.
Um,
it's,
you know,
the idea that they've maintained this
sort of secret over a period of time.
I find hard to believe I'm not
discounting it.
And again,
you've got to leave a little space open
for something that could be just
amazing.
But
anyway,
so that's,
that was that.
But I,
yeah,
I agree that shot was not,
uh,
was not a tough shot.
One meters ain't shit and that's nothing
in particular in those conditions.
And I will say those conditions were
ideal.
Unfortunately for that event.
People are like,
there's a video of me shooting a fucking
hard drive at a hundred yards,
a hard drive and you must have hit it
that hard drive edge.
Well,
we getting rid of some hard yards,
thought it'd be fun to take it to the
rifle range,
so I'd take it to the rifle and
obviously we're dealing with modern
rifles are probably more accurate,
but I'm shooting something that's
basically two inches high,
laying it down on the ground at a
hundred yards and blown to smithereens.
That's how accurate a rifle is at a
hundred yards.
You tell me he couldn't get a headshot
at 81 meters.
That's crazy.
Again,
no,
she caught wind.
Of course he could go to light.
Did he go with he?
That's really the question is,
you know,
we have some pretty good indication as
to what he was thinking and what is
obviously what his motivations were and
that's important.
It definitely was in with the Russians
definitely was involved in a lot of
weird shit with communism.
Who knows what his entire full
background was because there was a lot
of covert shit going on.
Did he?
Did he express a desire to do something
like this to the Russians at some point
and they know that,
okay,
well here's an interesting opportunity,
right?
Yeah.
They would have,
they would have sparked on that and they
would have thought about it.
They would,
they have actually,
you know,
play on words intended,
but would they have pulled the trigger
on an operation trying to push him into
doing an act like this indirectly
through the Cubans.
Exactly.
Especially if like this crazy fuck Mike,
go ahead and do this for us.
So after the Bay of Pigs,
people have to realize there was a lot
of people pissed off at Kennedy,
we lost
bullshit.
Hated Buddy.
Christian hated Kennedy.
Yeah.
And so,
well that infamous video where he's
banging his shoe down on the table.
We will bury you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no,
it was,
it was the,
the environment was right for them and
they.
And again,
the Russians.
It shouldn't be a surprise to anybody
when you talk about what they did during
this election.
I mean they've been doing this forever.
There you go.
Back to the 19 forties and the Russians,
were you spending a lot of time and
effort and money here in the states
trying to keep us out of the war?
Back before Hitler invaded Russia,
when they were allied with the Nazi
still,
so they spent a lot of time.
They set up independent association.
Supposedly
they paid off a lot of unions and union
members,
a journalists.
I mean they were doing everything they
could create this or to strengthen the
idea of isolationism just to keep us
out.
They've been doing this for as long as
they've been around.
So anybody who says,
well,
I can't.
You know,
it's,
it's shocking.
The Russians will be engaged in this is.
It's ridiculous.
They've always been.
Again,
we by the way have been engaged doing
that with them.
What?
That's what I hear.
Fine.
I've heard that online.
I find that hard to leave.
The thing that bothers me the most about
the Kennedy assassination is the
universal support for the magic bullet
theory.
I think that fucking bullet is
ridiculous.
I've shot things.
I've shot a lot of things.
I know what happens to bullets.
Everybody that I know that's a marksman,
everybody knows it's a hunter.
They see a bullet that has hit bone.
It fucking never looks like that.
When a bullet goes through to people and
comes out looking like you shot it into
a pool of water,
that's what it looks like.
I don't buy that at all.
And the convenience of finding it on
Connolly's Gurney and they enroll them
into the hospital.
Oh look guys,
we found the bullet.
Got It.
And it's perfect.
God,
I don't buy that for a second.
And the problem is there's more metal
fragments in connally's body.
Then we're missing from the bullet
itself.
I think that bullet itself,
look at that bullet.
Get the caddy.
That thing didn't hit shit.
Uh,
it's exactly right.
The conditioned with this with people
that have never shot guns.
And they go,
well actually proven that broke bones
and a bullet breaks bones.
They get fucked.
Melissa jacketed bullets.
When it's jacketed bullets breaks bones.
It gets fucked.
You're talking about something that's
going.
I mean,
how fast is a bullet from that rifle go.
It's got to be that.
It would be interesting thing to pull
up,
but I would imagine it's in the
thousands of feet per second.
It's got to be.
When it hits bone,
it's going to it as well.
There's always distortion.
Even if you're.
I mean,
so I don't know when you have a
conversation about this and it is
somebody who has no shooting experience
or you know,
it just,
I think.
All right,
that's fine.
I understand why you're fascinated by
it,
but do,
when you do your research,
you know,
it's,
it's like with news,
read everything,
right?
Read The Wall Street Journal,
read The New York Times,
read the Financial Times,
read,
read the economist.
I read everything.
Yes.
Before you form your opinion.
Right?
And,
and,
and everybody is so siloed nowadays and
you get the same thing with conspiracy
theories.
I absolutely believe this and I'm not
going to,
I'm going to discount everything else
that's out there and,
or just not pay any attention to it.
Um,
yeah.
But it's hard to say.
And here's another thing,
the magic bullet path.
People like,
well,
how is that possible?
Well,
let me tell you something that's the
most believable thing about the magic
bullet.
There is the path of the bullet because
bullets do wacky shit when they hit bone
and you can't predict it at all.
I know a guy who,
uh,
in Iraq,
they shot a guy in the head from the
front and it went out as eyeball.
The bullet came out of his eyeball back
forward.
It ricocheted inside of his skull and
came out as I know you can't.
I mean,
again,
you can't put you right,
you can't predict it.
They'll try to model these things and
figure out a way,
but you know,
there's an unknown there.
And so yeah,
I agree.
I mean,
I think that again,
it's,
it's one of those things where it,
it,
it's never going to get resolved and it,
it's going to continue to live on
because a,
it was such an important event in the
history of the country.
And B,
it's,
I keep going back to that same thing.
People don't want to believe that really
awful shit can happen sometimes in a
very simple,
straightforward way.
And so it's much easier to think it was
a broad base conspiracy.
There were lots of moving parts,
sometimes bad shit happens and it's just
as simple as it seems that is possible.
Conversely,
people don't like to believe in
conspiracies,
especially when it's involved in an
assassination of president.
Right.
You know the reason why they came up
with the whole magic bullet theory in
the first place is pretty shady in the
first,
in fact,
the reason why they did it because the
guy got hit by a ricochet underneath the
overpass and they blamed that bullet on
one of the,
one of the shots from Lee Harvey Oswald
and the book depository.
So they said,
well,
all right,
so now we have less bullets that could
have hit Kennedy.
We have all these wounds and we have to
attribute a series of wounds to one
bullet.
Right?
Right.
So that was the thought process behind
it.
But this is approved.
Or film was the one that got people
weirded out by it.
But I'll tell you about men.
I've watched that film a bunch of times
and one of the things that don't jive is
if he did get hit from the front,
you know,
head goes back to the left.
Why is the blood spray out forward?
See,
it's,
it's weird the way the impact of the
blood is,
the blood sprays forward and then his
head goes back into the left.
It could have possibly been that he was
hit from the front end,
the back at the same time.
That's entirely possible.
I mean,
that is a tactic you would do,
right?
You would roll someone into an area
where they would be in a crossfire and
they'd get shot if they came in.
If there was,
if the grass,
you know,
it was in fact a second site for a
shooter.
Then by the time it hits that corner and
starts its path just before the shots
were fired from the book depository and
Oswald,
if you,
if you're going with that,
if you had an another shooter up on the
grass,
you know,
you're,
you are basically looking right at the,
the,
uh,
the front of the vehicle.
And because of the way that it's
positioned in the nols kind of turned
and then it's just that,
it's just that there's not a lot of
concealment up there.
And they had that.
They had the fence,
picket fence.
It's not the original one that Sarah
anymore,
but it's basically in line with it.
And you can see there's plenty of
pictures of the.
Oh,
the previous fence,
it was up there at the time.
Um,
and you had that,
you did have the train yard engineer
report sometime after the fact that he
saw a puff of smoke and he wasn't quite
sure what that was all about and he'd
seen a couple of people back there so
that,
you know,
that was,
that's an interesting thread to pull on.
Right.
And,
and I think that,
that it's been,
it's been ad nauseum doesn't mean that
you couldn't still find something.
It also doesn't mean anybody's going to
really find a conclusion after the fact.
Right.
Firstly,
today.
Yeah.
No.
And that's right.
And you know,
maybe it's like everything else,
as time marches on,
you lose,
you lose witnesses,
you know,
people that were there on site and even
witnesses when someone gets shot.
No,
especially with the precedent is not
credible.
Five different stories from five
different people and gunshots heard from
the moon.
Nobody will get that just from a
robbery,
just straight driving in a car accident
you'd say you'd say,
what did you see?
If you have separate people out,
you're right,
you'll get five different versions from
five different people and you know,
so yeah,
I wasn't a witness accounts.
I tend not to be a particularly a
credible and you've got to,
you know,
you,
you got to take them and then you gotta
match it up with other information that
you can,
you can pull together forensically.
But it's a,
it is fascinating.
I know who knows where it's going to DB
Cooper's back in the news a little bit
because it really.
Yeah.
They've uh,
initially it was because the bureau was
saying,
okay,
we're,
we're closing this case.
And then there's some talk now over the
past day and a half,
two days that they might've found
something up in the wilderness that
might be a piece of the shoot that he
had.
And I know they haven't,
they haven't bought them that one out
yet.
But Cooper,
more new evidence of parachute believed,
found.
But how they know that's his parachute.
Yeah.
The thing about,
I mean,
it could be,
but the thing about something that's
that long ago,
we have to realize how many people die
in the woods every year.
Yeah.
And when you go,
when you come out the back of that
plane,
I'm good luck.
Yeah.
And,
and also he was in a suit.
He was wearing loafers.
He lost his shoes.
So he hits those,
that wilderness.
He hits those trees and uh,
it was cold that night and it was wet.
And there's going to be a man hunt on,
in the morning.
No,
he had his,
um,
a parachute and he had the bag with the
money.
They'd given him money.
So.
And that,
that was it.
And so I'm no wilderness gear at all.
No.
Well not that they know of.
I mean,
who knows,
maybe underneath his business suit he
was wearing something,
but I'm just going to be wearing.
So what was the time of the year?
Uh,
it was late in the year I think.
I think I have to go back and check
again,
but I think it was November,
I want to say part of the country up in
the,
uh,
the wilderness up in Washington state.
Oh,
he's dead before thanksgiving.
Before thanksgiving.
Yeah.
That guy's dead.
I mean it's just not going to make you
make your way out of there.
And it's nighttime and you know that.
And,
and you know,
they again,
there's going to be a manhunt starting.
No,
let's.
Trout wouldn't survive up there,
but there's been all sorts of theories.
Oh,
he jumped out and then some people met
them.
Well,
maybe good luck finding them.
Right.
How are you going to be able to be so
silly?
People jumping out of an airplane with
no gps.
Do the odds of finding that guy and he's
not,
he doesn't have a flare.
Like what does,
what does he have?
How are you going to look at?
I'm going to just find him in the woods.
That's why I think there's,
you know,
there was some talk,
well,
you know,
because some of his money was found,
um,
you know,
after the fact stacked in a,
in a little,
uh,
a part of the river that seemed unusual,
right?
It seemed like it would have had to make
a pretty amazing journey from the
wilderness down through the stream
system out to the river and then be
found on this sandbar and it was all
stacked one on top of the other,
but it had the light,
it had the serial numbers.
And so there was some thought that,
you know,
how did that get there?
Did it naturally just float down there
and ended up on the sandbar and covered
in Santa.
Eventually was found by some kid that
was on a picnic.
Whoa.
You know,
I'm wondering if that's slowly,
how long would it take for you get
busted.
And that was $200,000 back in the day,
a little bit here and there.
Now buy a bicycle.
Seems good by TV.
No one saying nothing but bicycle.
These little kid,
you know my way to California where the
weather's coming,
room's got a 50 inch tv with the fuck's
going on.
You don't even have a job be what the
hell are you doing?
Where did you get that transistor radio?
Well,
if it's a kid who found it,
I'm sure I see what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
he reported the kid was with his family
and he reported finding Amelie.
That bureau went out there and dug up
the entire area and in a fairly large
effort trying to figure out what is
there more money there?
How did it get there?
Run tests.
I think if they found his money,
he's dead.
It's not going to jump out of a
parachute and then leave the money.
There was some thought that maybe he was
doing it as a ploy,
right?
To,
to kind of distract and think,
okay,
he's dead because the money's there.
Uh,
but again,
it falls into the category of,
you know,
it's never going to be resolved,
I don't think.
And it's a fascinating story.
It's Americans only on solved hijacking.
Am I right about that?
I think Americans only unsolved does it
all the money.
Did they find all of it or what?
It was just a small amount.
It was not,
it was not a large amount.
So he did not.
If he,
if he planted the theory was smart
enough not to put it all their weird
story.
That db cooper one's a weird one because
a lot of people,
they tend to look at him like some sort
of a folk hero.
There was a connection with him that
they were,
they were thinking he was this guy who
up,
I want to say shot family members and
murdered family members and then went
out and did that crime.
There was some suspect that was on the
loose from some sort of a homicide that
they connected to the DB cooper case and
they thought that somehow there was a
potential that they were related,
that it was the same guy.
Yeah,
he loses some of his charm.
If that's the case.
Yeah,
it'd be just a guy that's,
you know,
thinking I'm going to hijack a plan for
some cash.
And where'd he get the money?
Where did the cash come from?
They brought it on the plane and they
landed and then they gave him the money
that they got the passengers and the
most of the crew off of there.
And then everybody was in the cockpit
with the door closed when the,
in the old days in the back door would
open up the steps and he went out the
back door.
They had a backdoor indicator,
which is how they kind of sensed about
where he would have gone out.
And uh,
anyway,
I sound like a db cooper.
So how high was he up there when he
jumped
again?
I have to go through my notes,
but I think commercial flight.
No.
Oh No,
no,
they,
they dropped down to,
I want to say about 10,000 feet.
I can't remember,
but they're not really sure because the
door came down.
He could've been there for any period of
time and he had instructed them to drop
down.
I forget again what altitude he was
head,
but you know,
it's just,
it's amazing that these things continue
to go on and we love mysteries.
I love mysteries and conspiracies and
uh,
which is why the new trump
administration is so interesting.
Well,
he loves conspiracies,
doesn't he?
He believes a bunch of crazy ones.
Like he was just a retweet that one
about,
um,
what was the general that uh,
they,
they attraction to pershing dip in the
pigs.
Uh,
the bullets in pig's blood.
Yeah.
And there was never an attack,
uh,
Islamic attack at 35 years.
That's not even a true story.
Know who?
But again,
who,
why?
Why aren't you doing this?
Why it just stop?
Yeah,
it does.
There's no,
there's no like,
I didn't vote for him.
I didn't vote for her.
I,
I just thought we could have done better
in a country this size.
Right.
Tell you one thing he's doing.
He's fucking it up for future idiots.
Idiots.
Oh No,
no.
I would not underestimate our ability to
hire somebody worse.
I'm never going to be as someone like
maybe there'll be like a new version of
him,
like someone like him,
but they dial it back a little bit.
Yeah,
yeah.
Maybe so.
I just think people always say,
well,
this will be a course correction and
we're going to go back to having really
respond and I'm thinking,
wow,
this is America.
Don't,
don't,
don't imagine that it could actually get
better in that regard.
We could be even more dysfunctional from
a political point of view,
but what's weird is I was watching this
interview today where this guy is
fucking pencil neck dork was supporting
and Tif of violence and saying that the
only way to fight against fascism is
violence.
And I was like,
oh Jesus.
And then there was this other guy next
to him who was saying,
no,
that's not true.
The way you fight it is with a peaceful
protest like just happened in Boston.
Like that's the best way to handle it.
Where there was,
I want to say there was more than
100,000 people in Boston wasn't there
was how many people in Boston came out.
Let's see if we could find that out,
and it was completely peaceful in the
the.
I think there was like 400 retards with
KKK banners.
It's a small,
small group of assholes and you're like,
okay,
but here's the thing.
This is where,
this is where the,
you know,
president trump has just such a.
he's a great case study at some point,
I'm sure.
Well,
I'm sure people are already,
you know,
writing up their grant proposals to do a
study on,
on his psychology.
But you know,
you look at,
you look at at the first amendment and
you think if you like the first
amendment,
then you got to be all in,
right?
It's not like you can say,
and that's the kind of the beauty of
this country.
You got to let that a douchebag speak.
Right?
And that's what it is.
It's speech.
But we've gotten to the point now
words some by some folks are viewed as
violence.
Words aren't violence.
I don't think.
This is just my own personal opinion.
Boards on violence,
you gotta let everybody speak because
that's the first amendment.
You,
you'd go down and they don't want to
pick and choose in slope,
slippery slope.
Right?
And so,
you know,
we,
we can all agree that there is no space
for them.
They're assholes,
but there's also no space for violent
counter demonstration.
There is space for protesting it because
it's,
they're absolutely wrong.
Right?
I mean,
that's,
that's again,
this idea that you,
how you should be able to argue both,
right?
No,
you can't respond with violence and yes,
you guys,
you shouldn't,
you shouldn't be here.
If you're going to hold those views,
that's,
it's important.
You are protected by the first amendment
and so that's fine.
Doesn't mean we have to like it or in
any way condone it,
but,
but you get an okay that those sort of
fringe ideas are going to exist.
And I agree the best way to resolve it
is peaceful demonstrations,
massive pieces does demonstrations to
show,
you know,
sort of the weight of where the good
thoughts are and then a political
process,
right.
And sure that,
you know,
work through the political system as
dysfunctional as it may be.
But anyway,
uh,
just encouraging people to violently
attack people that have differing ideas
in them that aren't being violent is
never the answer.
No,
it's just not the way to do it.
And that's just the approach to.
Yes,
you're right,
it takes a fascist approach.
Yeah.
I mean literally you're enforcing your
ideas to the point where you're
silencing others with actual violence.
The mark of a totalitarian state also is
if you say you can't have these views,
will get that to hate those views.
But again,
it's the idea that what you say is
violent to me.
No,
it's not.
It's fucking speech.
The other thing that trump fucked up,
he called those protesters.
Anti violent protesters.
Like anti-police protesters.
Yeah.
Like,
come on
man.
That is not what they're protesting
against police.
There might be a few amongst them that
say stupid shit.
But,
but again,
just like with the other side where
you've got what do you,
what do you got?
A $100,
$200.
Who would imagine $15,000?
What the fuck are these Nazis hiding?
Anyway,
that's it.
That's the thing.
You know,
my dad didn't,
didn't fly in World War Two,
you know,
so that somehow you could have a
resurgent,
not that there is,
I think it's a small group just like
it's a small group on the left that
wants a violence solution to this or you
know,
honestly believes that violence against
police is somehow the answer,
which is insane.
But,
um,
again,
there you go.
Truth is somewhere in the middle,
right?
I mean,
they've got to get rid of the fringe and
you know,
we got to figure out a way for the folks
that are in Canada.
Summoned space.
Yeah.
I have to work together.
Otherwise,
I mean a,
I don't think the Democrats care whether
Republicans gave.
In fact they are,
they're happy.
That shit's not getting done.
But as an American,
again,
I didn't vote for him.
I didn't vote for her,
but I would like to see the government
work now.
Who did you vote for?
A.
You know what?
I just said,
fuck it.
I can't.
I couldn't youtube.
I know I couldn't bring myself to do it.
I couldn't bring us and I hated doing
that.
Right.
Because I voted top down right now,
what they call it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
what I did was I,
you know,
state elections important,
those sort of.
And that's fine,
but it,
it,
uh,
it's very painful to say I can't,
you know,
can't justify doing that and uh,
and I know people and then people lose
their minds and they go,
well,
that means you have voted for him or
that means.
And I know it just means we should have
been able to do better in a country this
size,
you know,
and um,
maybe maybe you hold your nose and vote
for the other side.
I don't know.
Um,
but at least she represented a
conventional approach to politics.
That's true.
There's no doubt about that.
That's super conventional.
I don't enjoy a lot of aspects of her
personality and what she's done with her
career and the obvious deception.
The Clinton Foundation,
which is just riddled with problems and
now doesn't even exist anymore.
Apparently they shut it down to wonder
what they did with the remaining balance
as a horror is flying in from Russia.
What are we going to deal with this?
We got all this money.
We're got to transfer it somewhere.
There's got to be a place to store it in
my pants,
wad up hundreds stuff and I'm in his
past.
He was,
he was in a marriage or is.
I guess he's not dead yet,
so I don't want to kill them off,
but he's,
he's,
he's an amazing political individual.
That guy could make you think that,
you know,
I met him once overseas is sounds dodgy,
but in the Saudi at a,
a party that does sound really sketching
and so.
But he had that ability right now again,
I wasn't a fan.
That's,
but I,
you know,
again,
you just want whichever administration
is in charge.
You want it to work you from country to
move forward.
But yeah.
But so you met him in it and it's true
what people used to say about them,
which is that he made you feel like he
was talking right to you and nothing
else was important.
Right.
He wasn't one of those guys that looks
over their shoulder thinking,
ms dot somebody else.
I should be talking to over there and he
was a charmer friend of mine told me he
was talking to him and a woman though
and Clinton like essentially almost
turned his back to him and like all the
horse out of the picture.
Then he just pressed gun.
I'm just gonna Block you right here.
So these honors,
I got a stack name a pockets man in a
party.
A party in Saudi.
Get drunk
with that dude.
Yeah,
I'll tell you what's.
I mean George Bush.
That'd be a guy like to sit down and
have a beer with the Bush family.
Good bunch.
But I know people that go,
oh my God,
I couldn't stand with policies.
But you know,
sometimes you just,
it comes down to a personal thing and
you think,
yeah,
you know,
maybe the guy's got some,
you know you made.
I like his principles.
You may have,
but he sticks with them.
Right?
He looks extremely reasonable now.
Yeah,
exactly right.
One time where the supreme court had a
ruling that he didn't like and there was
a speech where he gave in the.
I've seen it quoted in print and then
someone showed a video of it,
but he was essentially saying,
well,
you know,
we have to uphold the decision of the
court,
you know,
I'm not happy with it,
but you know,
this is uh,
the way our system works.
And then it went to trump talking about
the supreme court,
you know,
not backing his travel ban and all the
different various things that he's lost
in court and he just goes out and he
just said,
and I just like the personal attacks and
there's no product,
there's no discipline in the White
House.
And,
and I know that everybody thought,
well,
let's get something different in there.
Let's get a businessman.
Let's,
we don't want the politics as usual.
And well you got that,
but there is a requirement.
There is a need for the machine to work
in a certain fashion and in a sense.
And yet,
you know,
yes,
there's lots of things you can change
and that that's a good thing.
There should be some change in the
government,
but the way the place works in
Washington,
but the communications there that the
lack of discipline,
I mean for crying out loud,
they just,
they just put in place the new
communications director at the White
House,
28 years old.
She's 28 years old,
never done this sort of thing before.
And she's the new communications
director.
She replaced Scaramucci for his 10 days
of rain.
And why did she,
um,
wanted to replace him?
Because she listens.
She's just willing to do what trump
says.
He just said,
yeah,
I'm here for the job.
I mean,
she says you're the girl for,
you know,
for this.
And she's,
she's worked within the trump
organization and I guess just viewed as
loyal.
Loyal.
Yeah.
That's what he needs.
He needs loyalty above all else.
Yeah.
And so,
so that's it,
but I mean,
there's no consistency and you see these
things happen.
You'll see,
you know,
these,
the messaging get out and he gets ahead
of the message or they need to play
catch up then.
And people like Madison,
John Kelly now and Pompeo and others are
trying to race to make sense of some of
these things and they just self
inflicted wound after,
after wound for this,
this administration,
it seems like one of those homemade
derby carts that they rolled down the
hill where you know,
the wheels aren't going to stay on and
you kinda can't look away.
Like,
wow,
how long is it going to take for this
thing completely falls apart,
start doing tumbles down the hill.
You got a name,
they get it.
You got to come up with a name for that
cart is have the name,
your soapbox derby cars.
But um,
yeah,
I,
I don't,
I don't know where it's going to go.
I just think I'm the guy who has been in
the intelligence community for so many
years and you're stepping back and there
was also a real issue with him being at
odds with the intelligence community and
diminishing the intelligence community.
Yeah.
That was a strange error.
Sort of an interesting narrative.
It didn't really.
It got overblown to some degree.
I mean the people in the sense that the
people at the agency,
you know,
at the end of the day,
they just take whoever's in charge.
They take their marching orders from,
right.
It's not,
and I know people don't believe it
because you know,
everybody likes to feature films and
everything,
but it's,
it's a pretty apolitical organization.
Whoever's in the administration,
they're going to prioritize their
national security concerns.
You're tasking comes out of that and
then you just march on and do your job.
And yes,
the is an appointed position and you
know,
John Brennan was certainly much more
political in the previous administration
than,
than a previous directors have been.
But,
and the operational level,
the street level people just get on with
it,
you know,
they're human.
So of course,
you know,
they may have their own personal
preference,
but I spent a long time.
They're in behind the curtain and,
and you know,
they just tick on and do whatever.
You know.
There were people that weren't happy
with Obama.
There are people that weren't happy with
Bush to people not happy with trump.
That doesn't just tell us what the
priorities are,
tell us what the task is and we'll get
on with it,
you know,
go out there and do the collection
operations we're supposed to do.
It just seems like there's no one person
that's ever going to be able to fill
that position.
It seems like that position also gets
bigger and bigger,
like the responsibilities get bigger and
bigger and the president's.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just,
it seems to me that at this point in
our,
our history,
the history of our society,
we kind of have to look at that position
and wonder whether or not it's even
logical to give so much power to one
person.
It was like,
what would you do?
I mean,
how do you have a good question?
Yeah.
How do you create a Council of Elders
Council?
Everybody sits around like a hand carved
desk in a underground layer and makes
decisions.
That's a good.
Yeah,
I like it.
Yeah.
It could be like the knights of the
round table,
but I think it's.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know.
I think virtuous people by committee.
I wonder if the founding fathers,
you know,
I'm sure there's been all,
reporting on that,
I just never read it,
but the founding fathers,
have they considered that as an option,
as an option?
Probably not,
but a wonderful committee.
The kind of population growth that we've
experienced here,
the real problem with the founding
fathers is as brilliant as they were.
There's no way that could have ever seen
the internet coming now,
and this is what could they have seen
the people wanting to stay in Washington
for 36 years,
42 years.
I've become career politicians.
They were all just interested in,
in,
you know,
doing their duty and serving the way
they were supposed to or they felt
obligated to and then getting the hell
out.
Right.
Getting back to the farm or whatever
that job was because nobody wanted to
stay in Washington for any longer than
they needed to.
So yeah,
you're right.
They could,
they have foreseen all.
No,
definitely not.
And so does that mean,
what does that mean though?
It means amendments to the Constitution
and as we've done in the past and think
about how crazy it is that someone forms
a new country and then 400 plus years
later,
it is the preeminent superpower in the
world by far.
Yeah,
that's pretty crazy.
You got these countries that have been
around for thousands and thousands of
years,
like imagine a group of freaks and
misfits that branch off from America,
getting a boat and float over to Costa
Rica or wherever and take it over.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
and then it becomes the superpower.
It is astounding.
And then again,
going back to what we talked about
towards the beginning was cobbling it
together and understanding that we
needed to get our hands on everything
west of the Mississippi.
Now,
clearly there were some issues there,
but you know,
it's sort of that vision that says we're
going all the way to the causeway.
The water we have to.
It was,
we can control it.
Right.
And that's,
I mean,
it's,
it's an astounding history.
You're absolutely right.
Um,
but,
you know,
it'll be interesting to see.
Obviously this is the probably the
stupidest statement people will hear it
all day is,
is you know where we're going to be in
say another 200 years because I've got a
theory that says we're.
Every generation is making it easier for
their kids and eventually you hit a
point of diminishing returns and
everybody's just a big pussy and so
that's my theory.
I haven't come up with a name for it.
You're not alone.
Yeah,
a big pussy pussy.
That's.
That could cover different things.
So yeah.
Plus that was great.
That was a great show.
Wonder.
Yeah.
I wonder how much there's going to be.
There are parts of the world where
obviously things are way more difficult
than are here and maybe we're losing
some sort of a competitive edge because
we've made our lives so easy and haven't
replaced the convenience of civilization
with something that tempers are human
instincts,
like some difficult tasks,
right?
Of passage for young men,
you know,
something that develops character.
Instead we're making safe spaces and
making words,
violence and you know,
making it so we have trigger warnings
and
no winters.
Winter when we don't have to,
when,
thank God my kids are getting old enough
now where their sports leagues no
longer,
you know,
for awhile there I was just driving me
crazy.
So it was parent go into a game and
realizing that they weren't keeping
score because they didn't want to hurt
anybody's feelings.
That's the whole reason why people get
better.
You fucked me.
And while the kids are keeping score,
the kids know for sure and kids don't
want you to blow smoke up their ass,
right?
You don't want to.
They'd come off the court and if you
know the,
the oldest boy a scooter,
he 10 years old and he's,
he plays a lot of Lacrosse.
He's been playing for five years and so
he's,
he really likes it.
And he does.
He does well.
But you know,
I'm not raising the Division One
champion there,
right?
But he plays other sports too.
So there's sort of a well roundedness
day.
But we came off the field one day and we
were walking along and,
and uh,
they,
all,
the parents were kind of marching off
and the game was over and he says,
he says,
how'd I do?
And I said,
well,
you know,
you could've done better.
Um,
I said,
I just get the impression you didn't try
as hard as you could,
what do you think?
And he looked at me,
irritated.
He looked at me like,
I can't believe you didn't just say I
did great.
And so he said what?
And I looked at him,
I'm walking and I didn't realize the
parents were within earshot.
And I said,
well look,
you know,
school,
do you want me to blow smoke up your
ass?
Do you want me to be honest with you?
And to his credit,
he said,
be honest with me even though it wasn't
happy about it,
the honesty.
So you just be honest with me.
And so we,
we tell kids that they know better.
You know,
if you tell a kid that they're great and
they're doing wonderful and they didn't,
what do they take away from that?
They take away from it that you're kind
of bullshitting them unless they're just
super,
super young.
They're pretty.
They get it at a pretty early age.
Well,
here's,
here's something that's important to
relate to children that you are not your
accomplishments.
You are you,
and the only way you're going to get
better at accomplishing things is to be
100 percent honest about the amount of
effort you put in and what the actual
result of that effort is.
Whether it's a failure or a success that
does not define you,
that defines your participation in this
particular activity.
It is not you.
You are an individual that will
hopefully learn from all of your
endeavors,
but you're never going to learn shit if
you lie to yourself.
He never going to learn shit.
If somebody makes this nobody's scores
employment and there are no winners and
there are no losers and everybody's
amazing that that's not good because it
gives voice.
By the way,
it's not good because there's going to
be people out there that are fucking
driven and psychotic and they're going
to get ahead.
There's people that are task oriented
and goal oriented it and they they have
an idea ahead of them are going to try
to figure out how to make this happen.
They have a goal,
they want to reach it,
and if you're competing with that person
in any form of life and they're not
burdened down by the bullshit that we
give so many kids today,
they're going to have a massive
advantage and this idea that this kid
who's been coddled and treated like he's
always going to be a winner,
that somehow or another they're going to
be happier is fucking crazy.
Kid can't process what's true and what's
not and the kid can't process criticism,
constructive criticism,
right?
You don't just stand there and berate
you're kid.
Of course.
That's just as bad as the other.
Yeah.
No,
absolutely.
The guys that stand on it and
everybody's seen them.
Right.
That the Dads,
sometimes moms that stayed on the
sideline and berate their kid because
kids jeopardizing his scholarship to
some more on school.
Yeah,
morons,
but no,
I think
you're absolutely right.
They've got.
The sooner they're able to assess that,
that equation effort,
a end result and compare it to what's
going on around them and then understand
it.
I'm gonna say what am I?
And then one of my boys,
you know,
they play basketball and
they enjoy it,
but it's not their primary activity
right now.
So they tried out for a year and they
got and um,
but not at the top team and they were
upset about not being placed on this top
team.
And I said,
you don't,
I did.
And I didn't say it quite this way,
but my,
my,
my point was,
you don't deserve
to be on the top 10 because you're not
working as hard as those kids that are
working hard.
And that's their thing.
They wanted to be there.
And so they put in the effort,
you are happy playing and you could,
you could be there,
but you're not doing it yet.
And so therefore,
you know,
hey,
don't get down on yourself,
but b,
don't certainly don't get down on
anybody else because they put out the
effort and they accomplished something
that you didn't.
So you know,
you always trying to find that balance.
It's just I don't,
we're not doing our kids any favors
right now.
I just think we're,
we're not,
not obviously as a broad brush
statement,
but in general terms,
I think society is not doing us any
favors.
We're in and you see that I've got a
daughter that's in college and she talks
about her,
you know,
her classmates and others and you know,
sort of the conversations they have in
class and the discussions and what
passes as debate nowadays,
which is not much right.
The idea of the old debate where you
can,
you can voice your opinions and they can
be different than somebody else's and
you can hash it out and you can have a
winner and a loser,
but that's fine.
You Go away and you come back the next
day and you have another rousing debate
in that class doesn't really exist.
You know,
it seems like anyway,
because everybody's so afraid of saying
something that might be offensive or not
offensive,
but just might be upsetting.
And there's a difference between being
upsetting and being offensive.
We're trying to serve the world.
I mean that really was what we're trying
to.
All the hard edges that you might bruise
yourself on.
We're trying to push a,
put a cushion,
but you need to understand that when you
fall down,
it's going to hurt so that way next time
you're thinking you might fall down,
you'll correct your path because the
whole reason why people do difficult
things,
you do difficult things to understand
your boundaries,
to understand your limitations,
and then to try to improve those,
try to raise the roof on your
expectations,
raised the roof on your,
your,
whatever.
Limitations of your abilities,
learn from whatever those are and
improve.
It's like interrogation training.
You would an interrogation training when
you're working with people.
Um,
the goal is to show them that it's okay.
At some point they're going to have to
talk,
right?
And so when you're going through the
training,
the point of it is to get them to that
point.
They realized that,
okay,
you know,
it's not the end of the world.
I know that at some point I'm going to
end up talking,
right?
I'm going to say something,
I'm going to have to do that because I
can't,
otherwise I'm either dead or I'm
completely broken.
And the idea is if you do that and then
the rest of the training and,
and beyond that,
you're building them back up because
they understand that now if,
God forbid something should happen,
they get picked up and there's actually
an interrogation going on in the back of
their mind.
They understand that and they're able to
process it so that if they do get to
that point where now,
okay,
I'm going to have to talk.
I'm gonna have to come up with something
it's going to add.
And then it's not completely
devastating.
It doesn't,
you know,
leave them completely broken and they
can walk back because they understand.
I got to that point.
I understand what my boundaries are.
Uh,
but I can work within that.
I,
I don't know where I'm going with this.
So that we're seeing,
are you seeing turkeys and trading like
a,
an agent gets interrogated,
interrogation training in general for,
for,
for our outfit,
for the military.
Basically the same.
We do a lot of cross training.
This is not interrogating an enemy
combatant,
you being going through interrogation
training,
so what do you tell them to do?
Like in that,
like say if someone gets captured in
Afghanistan or whatever happened,
whatever bottom line is,
you know,
you,
you try to avoid talking,
but it depends.
Part of it is you've got to assess who
you're dealing with,
right?
You've got to assess what you think
their parameters are.
What could be coming down the pike in
other words.
So how is this and that.
That's part of the training too,
is understanding what different groups
with different places could,
could mean.
What would that would,
that interrogation could look like,
how bad it could get?
So you're processing that.
Part of it is understanding what it is.
It's okay to give up.
What are you,
what are you going to say that's not
going to put anything in jeopardy
anybody's lives or any operation or
anything in jeopardy.
Part of it is,
you know,
you've then you've got to understand
that you got to stay close to the truth.
Right?
The problem with it,
if you know where you start getting
people out on interrogations is where
they can't remember what they've said
and the closer you are to the truth,
the easier it is to remember what you've
said.
Right?
So in these things,
I mean,
if it's a bad situation and you're in
there day in and day out,
you know,
and your sleep deprivation and they're
knocking around and there's no food and
it's,
you're gonna have,
you're gonna have a hard time keeping
track of even the basic things.
So you know,
you're trying to keep it as close to the
truth as possible and as minimal as
possible.
You know,
in terms of,
of damage,
you go in,
you know,
typically you,
you've thought through all of this,
it's like everything else,
you do your homework ahead of time and
God forbid something should happen and
you know,
usually it won't.
But Anyway,
point being is that,
uh,
you know,
the ideas in the training portion of it,
you want people to understand that,
you know,
everybody's got a breaking point,
right?
And that's just,
that's the way it works.
And someone's summits,
you know,
it's here,
so I'm,
it's further down the road,
but everybody's going to break and you
don't want that to devastate the person
if it should happen,
you know,
knock on wood.
But anyway,
that was apropos of nothing.
Uh,
no,
it's important.
I mean,
it's an interesting topic because a mean
understanding that there's going to be
severe penalties and that there's going
to be repercussions there.
You know,
this is a,
this is a bad situation you're in and
understanding that going in is going to
help you a lot more than if you go in
there from,
you know,
a soft.
But how did world where you don't think
there's going to be any adversity
whatsoever.
No,
that's right.
And that's all we're,
you know.
Um,
just to finish that,
a thought is that the interesting thing
about people talked about the
interrogation program that we had
obviously,
right?
And I don't want to revisit that.
And you know,
the left at a very fine job of grabbing
the moral high ground and saying,
either you're talking to people or it's
all torture,
right?
Um,
but the point being is that even if you
don't ever intend to use any enhanced
interrogation
techniques,
you don't want to tell the enemy that
because once you tell them that you're
constrained by the army field manual as
an example,
that's all you can do.
Guess what?
Every milk out there fighting us and
wanting to harm us is carrying a copy of
the army field manual in their back
pocket.
They don't,
you know,
despite despite the fact that they did
for a while,
they don't live in a cave.
And so once they know what's coming down
the pike that's gone,
their incentive is gone right to talk to
you.
Because once you know,
once you don't have that unknown,
if you're not sitting in some,
you know,
a squat box and the temperature's up and
you haven't eaten and you're thinking,
what the hell they got to do to me next?
You have no idea.
If that's gone and you don't have that
anxiety,
that intense anxiety,
then you're okay with it.
Mentally,
you get yourself to a nice happy.
You're comfortable.
They're feeding,
you know,
they're just asking you questions.
They're just asking questions and
you're,
you know,
you can,
you can hold out for a much longer
period of time and yeah,
maybe there'll be some clever person
working in the interrogation facility
and they'll develop a personal
relationship over a period of time,
you know,
but you know what,
by then your operational information is
lost.
It's interest,
right.
And the shelf life on that stuff is,
is not particularly long typically.
So he had a way that says,
yeah,
when you,
when you're in a situation where you
have to extract information in a very
short period of time because it's
critical because lives are at stake,
like in taking time off and if you're
stuck in some situation where someone's
got a dirty bomb or what have you,
there's a terrorist attack is being
planned,
you know,
this guy has some information.
What is the best way to get it out of
them?
Is there a best way?
Yes.
You know what does not really,
because it's all dependent on the
individual and that's where it's so much
of this and it just again,
the,
the argument got sort of corrupted,
hijacked,
whatever.
Because of waterboarding,
because it just became such an emotive
issue,
uh,
but it's an enormously labor intensive
process.
Even in those cases where you think,
okay,
we've just picked up a high value target
and we feel that they've got operational
information that we really need to know,
uh,
related to whatever.
Um,
it's,
it's not as if you don't go in there and
start beating them over the head with a
two by four and nobody,
nobody does that,
you know,
maybe some,
maybe some liaison partners,
you know,
in,
fourth world countries,
you know,
would world fifth world.
What's the fifth world country?
I'd never even heard of that.
New Jersey,
Connecticut,
Connecticut outside of Dan Malloy is the
president of the fifth World Nation of
Connecticut.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's,
it's down to the individual is knowing
your homework.
It's,
it's having all the information that you
can at your fingertips about,
okay,
well who is this person where the
associates,
who else have we picked up and what have
they said up to this point?
Do you have anything like that that you
can walk into there?
If you walk into an interrogation and
you haven't done your homework,
you're screwed,
right?
It's going to show out really quickly
and they're going to figure it out for
the most part.
You know,
not to say that there every detainee
would be a lex Luthor,
but you know,
they get a sense pretty quickly so you
really got to have it buttoned up,
have as much information as possible so
that you know how to direct the
conversation.
If anything is said at all,
volunteered at all,
is there any credibility to it?
What can you do with that information?
You can take it back and get it
corroborated by another series
is a.
it's going to shut that off man series.
I'm transcribing everything you said.
No,
I ain't mad at doing that.
Well now what about,
what about using like chemicals?
Like what about like Mtma have they ever
tried given detainees ecstasy?
I'm no,
I mean I dunno.
Sixties,
you know,
maybe the 19 sixties.
I'm sure I would say.
And you'd be.
You'd be surprised.
It's taking a series still listening to
me that,
that big brother she knew.
Well,
I don't know what to do this to the
government.
It's,
it's google.
I hate to break it to Google,
but you can listen right now on youtube
to fucking covertly attack people's
phones doing that asshole stuff.
No,
it's.
You know what?
There's.
There are,
and again,
they might not know enough about
ecstasy.
I need to get on the team if I just
talked to them.
Get along.
I'm telling you,
you give these guys to hits.
They'll tell you everything because
getting massage,
that'll be your code name.
It'd be so nice to you.
It just changes everything.
That's.
There'll be so nice to you.
They'll just give him like some
delicious food and give them a back rub
and just go,
listen man,
America's awesome.
Tell me what you know about that plot
that we want to know about.
Blow anybody up,
man.
They can't be your friend.
How could you do that?
If you kill people that can't be your
friend.
Yeah,
I think that would work.
I don't know why we didn't think about
that,
but it seems like it wouldn't work,
but you know why you haven't done that.
Well,
there you go.
You've done it.
No,
that you go,
I've done it.
Trust me.
It'll fucking work.
Getting people to heads of ecstasy.
Acid,
a show.
I tell you what I'll do.
We'll get.
I will get on the jet and we'll go back
to headquarters and meeting saying is
bullshit.
I'm joking around the what that stuff
does is first of all,
it kills all of your inhibitions are
gone.
All of your anxiety gone.
All in,
all of your insecurities gone and what
you're left with is this over Saratonin.
Over dopa means state.
We just love everything.
And everybody,
if you could give that to enemy
combatants,
I guarantee you if you could talk to
them,
you would get shit out of them that they
would never want to discuss.
Yeah,
I think the
people will buy it when I say it,
but there are tremendous constraints on
what can and can't be done.
If people had gone through and actually
read all those dog
memos that were released,
me and buddy.
There you go.
That's what I'm talking about.
The chemist
coat on some fake glasses.
So I look,
look smarter than I am.
Give me a stethoscope,
maybe liking club Gary.
Just show up.
You take them out for a rave.
High water pants,
Italian shoes.
Now you're talking sort of the seventies
hustle.
Yeah,
just bring me in.
I'm telling you.
Just let me try it.
Once I could fix a lot of shit,
I'll put the idea forward.
I'll see what they say.
And then if you know the reason why they
don't think it would work because they
haven't done it yet.
If you get anybody in the viewer,
anybody in the ca or wherever who has
done ecstasy,
they would listen to this and they would
not want to say they've done it.
So it'd be a real issue.
But if you.
I'm telling you,
you give people two tabs of ecstasy and
then start asking them questions.
Plus also it would've been much happier
facility.
Oh yeah.
Can you open the next day?
Not the next day.
Next Day is rough.
He fucking.
I remember the first time,
well I only did it once,
but the next day I did it.
I quit.
I was in a coffee shop trying to read a
boxing magazine.
I literally could not read.
I was like,
God,
I can't even concentrate enough to read
a full sentence.
Like this is terrible.
And it was just pretty much that day
after.
No,
it's good to a couple of days.
That night I went onstage and I was
terrible.
I went on stage that night in Dallas.
If you went to that show back in 2001 or
whatever it was.
I'm sorry.
If I was apologizing.
Terrible show.
Well,
I just had no energy.
My brain was just like.
I felt like my brain was a dry sponge.
Like someone had just squeezed all the
juice out of my brain.
Yeah.
See it says after effects,
I just,
you know,
you're not worth it now,
but there's ways out of that.
There's a.
just keep on it.
No,
there's nutrients that you take called
five htp.
Five htp actually converts.
The serotonin in your brain is the
building blocks for it,
so what you do is while you're tripping,
you're supposed to double down on five
htp and it helps you as you come off of
it,
your serotonin jumps back up.
Oh,
not 100 percent though,
but to a manageable state,
who would.
You do have to be a chemist though to do
all that.
Right.
Just got to be discovered just by a
couple of tabs at the club,
you know,
call it good,
but if you're really smart,
you actually take l,
Tryptophan and five htp because El
Tryptophan converts to five htp and you
should also take adaptogens,
like some b vitamins and different
things as well.
That sense?
What?
Is that?
What's in Turkey?
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah,
but you just have a Turkey club,
nice Turkey club.
While you're that apparently that's
bullshit that crashed that people we say
from Turkey that you know,
it puts you to sleep.
Apparently that's all just carbs.
Oh yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
And massive amounts of mashed potatoes,
stuffing.
You just overeat and I can believe that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Although I do love stuffing.
Listen,
bring this information back.
I'm telling you,
you have to bring it back.
It's happening right now.
They're hearing us listening to the
watch center.
They don't know.
It's only because they don't know
Langley there taking notes right now.
You know he.
I am right.
I'm telling you.
I'm right.
Just try it once.
It doesn't hurt anybody.
They're not going to die.
You might
have to change some laws to to get that
to happen.
Last fucking nose ain't bring me in.
There's no laws.
No.
I show up with a suitcase and a smile.
Get you guys some UFC tickets.
We'll buy it.
We'll know.
We'll get you a lab coat.
Get Joe's special disguise.
Just let me try it once.
I guarantee just someone that some.
Someone who's not totally despicable,
like you just gotta like a little issue
with this guy talking.
It just changes your chemistry
immediate.
Just whittle.
It will erase any inhibitions.
You.
That sounds all very mengele like does,
but it doesn't hurt anybody.
That's the thing.
Yeah.
I think right now people are losing
their minds because we got back on the.
The interrogation thing,
everybody thinks I thought that was over
and done with.
Oh,
you on your side in the business.
Yeah,
just people in general.
I think everybody's just.
People just got so tired of it.
Tired of the war on terror.
Nobody wants to talk.
Oh,
not that I want to talk about it,
but that's what happens.
You think where's the end where you
know,
and,
and people just tired of it.
I just want to move on.
I don't want to think about it and
something happens and people are
reminded that it's still going on.
There's still people out there that want
to hurt you and yet we're all just so
exhausted from it.
Well,
I think that's also.
I mean,
you could,
you could make an analogy to some of the
stupid lies that trump has told that
tell so many lies that he just like,
I can't even be bothered.
This can't even be a scandal because
there's just,
there's so many of them.
You just get overwhelmed by it to the
point where you can't even.
He can't process it anymore.
It's exhausting.
And,
and the,
the idea that it kind of works both
ways,
right?
It works in the sense that the tweets
and the bizarre statements and the
things are exhausting.
And then on the,
you know,
the other side that people that want to
make all of that stuff,
the death of the republic every day,
it's the death of the republic that's
exhausting.
And you say who's,
who's running the shop,
who's keeping things moving forward?
And I don't know,
you know,
I mean,
we've got some good people in
governments,
really hardworking people for sure.
Trying to do the right thing.
And yet it's just a,
I'm not,
I'm not particularly confident right
now.
What do you think's the worst case
scenario right now?
So when you say you're not confident.
Um,
well I think we could have,
we could see the market,
you know,
kind of stall at this point.
I mean,
I think people have been amazed at how
the market was resilient and not just
resilient,
but you know,
a blasting upwards and showing
apparently no concern for,
you know,
how disheveled the administration has
been over the last several months has
been on a steady increase since 2007 or
so.
No,
the crash,
right?
Yeah.
But since that,
since the recovery of the long time,
it took a long time to come back,
but then.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean it's not,
it's not,
but what I'm talking about is the time
since the election,
you know,
the market's showed this ability to kind
of ignore what was happening.
Right.
What was sort of the chaos that the
media is reporting on and encouraged
though by his remarks about business.
You want to encourage tax cuts.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And the,
and some of the deregulation which has,
you know,
okay,
to be fair,
you know,
it's been a lot a fair amount of
deregulation.
Tax cuts not so much.
And so I think now that,
you know,
the market's starting to look at that
and think maybe we do have an issue
here.
Maybe it's not,
you know,
oh,
I'm going to work out the way we
thought,
so maybe that slows down.
I don't think North Korea is going to be
watching any missiles.
They're not suicidal,
right?
I mean,
they're not going to see.
And Kim Jong Gun.
What's the fuck's his name?
The basketball player with those shit
and his lips.
Rodman Rodman said Rodman over there
with a little Kim Yong.
And that's what I'm sad I can do.
That.
Definitely does ecstasy.
So that's that.
Now that I could get behind,
that's an operation we could,
we could work on know because that's not
targeting detainees and then have all
those regulations we've got to worry
about.
But I think,
you know,
if Rodman,
willingly offers up ecstasy and Kim
says,
fine,
then it's two consenting adults yet we
don't even allow Rodman to go back over
there anymore.
Right.
Was.
Yeah.
I think that Americans aren't allowed to
go back there and now,
but now,
right now I suspect,
although if Robin wanted to,
I'm sure he.
Yeah.
That's our answer to everything sent
Dennis.
He was a hell of a ballplayer in his
day.
People Forget.
People think Pacino.
He's such an interesting cat,
but people forget what a great
basketball player he was.
Yeah.
He just sort of went crazy.
Look at them.
Remember this picture?
Oh yeah.
Bad as I want to be.
Was that a bookie or something?
Well,
I mean you can't knock the guy for
trying to be unique.
Yeah,
no,
he's,
he's unique.
But he was again,
he,
he was a hell of a player.
Oh,
he definitely was mad.
A good look.
I haven't seen it one for.
I got a jacket just like tropical jacket
with all the palm trees and what he said
he's wearing around his neck.
His had a fishing net or is that.
It could be anything
mad.
It's like a silver Mr t thing.
See,
I could look at that and say I could
never pull that off.
I could never.
I couldn't do that for Christmas.
Yeah.
Halloween,
but not.
Not for Christmas.
Had Christmas and and besides it
Christmas when the season arrives,
I put on my,
my handmade New York giants,
a sweater from my daughter and I don't
take it off until after the Christmas
season as well.
Yeah.
It's pretty manky by now.
But yeah,
that's a great way to do that because
it's a giant.
Oh,
oh,
sort of giants.
One of those guys just cling to it to
cling to the past.
Glories maybe
not in the government anymore.
So.
No,
no.
I might those days or even the
possibility of those days just.
I mean,
unless maybe I get older and I just,
you know,
I want to see kids just slipped out of
tab,
you know,
and see what happens.
I told her to calm the fuck down.
Yes.
Yeah.
There's only one way.
Not told
my kids.
Okay.
If,
if things get bad,
if I start to,
you know,
I got blessed my,
my mom's 98 and she's all there.
She's great.
My Dad passed away when he was 90.
He was all there and uh,
and so I've got a knock on wood.
I'm hoping to make it a good long ways,
but
I've also seen folks deal with the
problem of,
you know,
onset dementia and Alzheimer's,
the problems that,
that creates horrible things.
I told my kids that I haven't told them,
but I told the oldest one is just we'll
that out to the back and you know,
you guys all take turns shooting abby
and whoever,
whoever wins gets the house.
So is that really what you told them?
What?
Yeah,
the oldest one.
I said,
shoot you.
He'll,
he'll win my ways.
It's pretty good shot.
Yeah.
But if then he'll go to jail.
You don't want that title.
Ho sure.
There's some law on the books that says
it's okay to,
you know.
No,
that's not true.
You're right.
Where do they have that?
Assisted suicide is in California,
California,
and I think Oregon.
You posted something about Idaho,
about people that were going up there
for the eclipse and I retweeted it.
It was fucking hilarious from the
sheriff's department,
Lincoln County sheriffs that that guy
knocked it out of the park because
everybody was thinking the same thing.
Everybody was like it because literally
the hippies,
I don't know,
maybe they're not hippie,
so I.
that's not fair,
but let's call them hippies.
Yeah.
They just,
they'd pull their,
their camper or their,
you know,
their,
their Volkswagen van again,
right out in the middle of a plant.
That field of freshly planted field
because it's not,
not,
not everything is fenced and gate it out
there.
Right.
There's a lot of space and you're like,
come on.
Or they'll,
they'll,
they'll take.
Like I said,
they'll take their prius up in the back
roads,
you know,
it's not going to make it.
The funny thing was about the dogs to
dogs riding the back of the truck and
occasionally some slow loaners took a
tumble,
but don't go to pet them.
They will bite you.
It's your truck.
It's their truck.
And you'll see that you'll see people,
hey,
they get upset because,
you know,
drive around with your,
your,
your dog in the back of the truck.
And B,
they'll,
they'll like walk up and why don't I
write pettit new thing?
Don't do that.
Don't do it.
You don't even know if he's a good dog,
but he,
that's his truck.
The other thing about people haven't
guns.
It's yes.
Everybody up here has a gun.
This is Idaho and the wildlife,
the wildlife will kill you.
I'll kill you.
And it will hurt the whole time you're
dying.
Yeah.
That sheriff,
it was great post.
We got great law enforcement or not.
I just got stopped.
I was uh,
we were up in the mountains and I was
racing to get to the airport on Sunday
yesterday.
And so I was coming through the canyon,
um,
and hidden back into boise from up in
the mountains and it's doing well.
I know what I was doing because the
sheriff told me what I was doing.
He stopped me.
He said even [inaudible] 76 and this is
a,
this is a nasty ass canyon following the
river,
you know,
for most of the way and you know,
you should be doing about 35,
40,
but I always just helmet,
you know.
And I was thinking I'm making good time
here.
And the sheriff was out because he's
trying to catch hippies and he stopped
me and we had it,
but they're just great.
You know,
that you,
if you show them respect and implied,
it's like a lot of places,
right?
It's not just idle,
but the guy was like,
you know what,
I'm sorry what to gave you to,
you know.
But yeah.
How's everything else?
And you end up chatting,
having a great time,
having a conversation.
You don't mind getting the ticket and
you know,
bob's your uncle.
But anyway,
we just white privilege of showing.
Yeah.
That's what's happening right there.
Is that what's happening to a bunch of
white privilege.
Right.
Tammy?
That,
you know what,
that's probably,
that's probably the case now.
I feel bad and I'm,
you know what I'm gonna do?
I'm going to,
I'm going to double what I sent in to
the county.
I'm going to pay twice the amount that I
should.
Well that's nice.
Just so that I,
I,
I self flagellate.
Yeah.
It's not like it's a hobby.
Most cops are great.
I've always said that.
I think that cops will look,
most people,
most people you run into her fine,
most people you run into a great,
occasionally you run into an asshole and
then you have a problem and then you run
around going all people.
We're all assholes.
No,
maybe one out of 100,
you know.
And I think with cops it's an insanely
difficult job.
Insanely stressful.
And you see that video,
that one officer who was trying to get
that fellow to stop and he was wearing,
he was wearing a body camera and so he
had,
he had asked him to stop and he matched
the description of a,
I think of robbery and um,
it's been on,
it's been on video of quite a bit.
And so the,
the officer is trying to get him to stop
trying to him to stop.
He won't stop.
He says I will tase you.
And he's coming around.
Right?
So He's,
the guy won't be take his hand out of
his pocket.
And that's what the officer sees that
his hands in his pocket when he gets
kind of starts,
you know,
pie in that chart.
There are any kind of gets around and he
sees the hand and he starts saying,
take your hand out,
take your hand and take in its body
cameras running,
and the guy pulls out a weapon and shoot
him repeatedly and it's just,
it's all there on kids.
It's,
it's a,
it's a perfect example of how difficult
that job can be.
Right.
And it's,
it's astounding.
So I know whether that video is
available.
Yeah,
it is available.
I've seen it.
Yeah,
there's,
there's a bunch of those.
I mean,
I've seen one of them where a guy pulls
over this one man and uh,
the guy was a Vietnam vet,
gets out of his car,
he's got a rifle,
was yelling at him,
get back to the car,
put the rifle down,
put the gun down,
and the guy starts shooting them and
he's shooting multiple rounds into the
guy's car.
And the guy started screaming.
Then he goes around by the passenger's
side and kills them.
It's all like on camera and video,
you have to realize this is a routine
traffic stop,
pulls them over for speeding or whatever
it was.
And this happens.
And it can happen all the time and
that's something that's on a cop's mind
every time he pulls somebody over and
you might think,
hey,
I'm a good person,
I'm not doing anything.
So I was going five miles an hour over
the speed limit,
you know,
why is this guy got his hand on his gun?
Why this guy freaking out?
Well maybe watch that video now.
Maybe he's thinking about his kids,
maybe he's thinking about getting home
to his family.
Right,
exactly.
And that's.
And there's nothing to.
And again,
this idea that you can't say two things
that some people might think,
oh,
that,
that counteracts.
Yeah,
anytime there's a,
you know,
a case of police brutality,
deal with it,
we got to deal with hard course,
but it's a terrible job.
It's a difficult job and it's a
dangerous job.
And those,
those two statements can coexist.
Right?
And there's so you can support the
police and you can also support efforts
to stop police brutality wherever it
takes place and ensure that it doesn't.
But you can also support the police and
the difficult job they do and the
efforts that they try to make them,
you know,
protect communities.
So
yeah,
the last thing you want to do is
alienate them further.
Mean that doesn't do anybody any good.
You denine the idea or the possibility
there are any good cops.
Well that's fucking crazy,
but it's a really convenient thing for
people to say fuck the police because
you don't get a lot of pushback.
Especially when something happens.
You don't get a lot of pushback.
You look like,
you know,
you're some sort of a liberal hero.
It's a very slippery slope.
And the people that want no cops.
Well,
okay,
well what about guns?
What are we going to do now?
You're going to just let criminals run
everything.
Yeah,
no,
no.
The good people with their flowers are
going to take over
shit.
Shit breaks down really quickly,
real quick and you know,
spend a long time overseas and some
pretty difficult environments and you
see sort of the worst nature of people
or you know,
and,
and you know,
and again,
I agree with it.
I think vast majority of people are
good,
you know,
they want to do good.
They want to do the right thing,
don't want conflict.
Most people don't want conflict,
right?
And,
and,
but,
but things can break down and people can
do things that other folks that are
trying to do the right thing couldn't
even imagine.
And uh,
yeah.
So anyway,
like shoot cops.
Yeah.
I mean you have to think I would never
shoot a cop wise's copy and so mean to
me because he doesn't fucking know you.
Right,
right.
You know,
it doesn't know you.
You're doing something wrong,
he's pulling you over and you've got to
comply and be polite and calm sir.
And try to diffuse the situation and be
as friendly and as polite as possible.
Yeah.
And that's not.
And again,
that's,
that's the same.
You can give your kid,
no matter who you are,
you can give your kid that same advice.
Look,
the law enforcement has a difficult job
and you know,
so just,
if you're stopped,
just comply,
comply.
Nobody's ever.
I mean,
I,
you just gotta you gotta be concise and
smart about that.
And I tell my kids out and I try to
demonstrate by like when I stopped you
and the sheriff came up and you know,
my kids were in the car and I,
I,
I was polite and I was saying,
and he got to the window and I said,
I don't have any excuse.
I was racing to get to the airport.
I was speeding.
I know it and I have no excuse.
And that sets the tone immediately.
And he understands right now it helps
it.
He looks in there and he sees a big dog
and the kids and everything and that
brings it down a little bit.
There's no doubt about it.
Um,
and so other situations they might be
more on edge because they don't know.
They're not sure.
And you know,
so yes.
Where there's problems,
deal with it.
We got to take care of it,
but we can also acknowledge the fact
that the police have a damn difficult
job.
Yeah,
and it doesn't mean that there horrible
mistakes
and horrible cops and people that are
under pressure to do terrible things.
You know,
mean there's some videos of people that
compliance still get shot.
It's,
yeah.
It's a terrible tragedy.
No,
absolutely.
They make mistakes.
They make mistakes or they had the wrong
mindset or they're not trained properly
and so their ptsd out and they're just
not designed for that job in the first
place.
Right.
I mean,
it's very difficult to tell who's going
to crack under pressure.
The pressure of the day to day situation
that a lot of cops find themselves in.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
um,
but the idea that you're right,
the idea that you'd remove law
enforcement and somehow we're all going
to live in a peaceful community.
Crazy anarchists driving me fucking
nuts.
Yeah.
We don't need laws,
man.
Shut your fucking mouth and get rid of
all the laws and universal basic income.
That's going to be a,
what did we do out the guns?
We've gathered them up and melt them
down,
not mine,
Make Martin Luther King Jr statues
everywhere.
And we know we were talking before the
podcast started about,
um,
what's,
uh,
what could possibly go wrong in
Afghanistan and that trump was
trump was going to make some sort of an
announcement and you were talking about
the idea of privatizing the,
uh,
the military over there and,
you know,
bringing in contractors,
talking about it from the point of view
that I don't agree with it.
I.
Yeah.
Um,
and I,
you know,
I,
in terms of disclosure,
right,
I mean,
my company intelligence,
we've got a security services group,
um,
and starting back in 2003,
we started building up a fairly
significant presence out in Iraq,
right as,
as private contractors providing support
to the infrastructure operations that
were going on out there.
And what's the benefit of having a
private contractor for the military as
opposed to like military force at that
time.
Most of our work was actually for the
infrastructure companies,
right?
Because the military is not providing
the support and they need the same level
of security and they have the burden is
building up some sort of a new business
there.
They would hire you guys to come in and.
Exactly.
And so that's an important effort
because you know,
they need the same level of security
that a forward operating base or a
military base or facility would need,
you know,
but the military is not going to
allocate resources for a private
company.
So a lot of what the private contractors
were doing was that.
And then also private contractors,
you know,
getting contracts to provide additional
security support or logistical support
to uh,
the military to military facilities
where they can't,
you know,
they,
they can't afford to allocate resources
to perimeter security and to the degree
that they would like.
So private contractors come in and help
with that or providing support in the
movement of dignitaries or whatever may
be a point being is we're out there for,
for quite some time in Iraq doing that.
And we were there at the beginning of
sort of this private contractor thing.
Right?
And people start becoming aware of it
and we started working with groups
including a Erik prince is a group we
didn't work directly with them,
but what I mean is the various groups
that are out there doing these contracts
and this work,
you know,
realizing that you needed to start to
form an association or started to get
some
sort of grip on how this thing would
look.
Right.
So that there was some consistency
amongst training and what were the
regulations for,
you know,
uh,
the various companies for,
you know,
weapons and everything else.
It's complicated,
but you know,
long story short is,
you know,
we had upwards of 400 people I guess out
there at a,
at a point providing security and
intelligence support.
So I've got some experience in this and
now what's happening with Afghanistan is
that one of the options that's been
being considered is,
is handing over.
We've got about an 8,400 troops out
there right now doing mostly training
missions,
training operations and support for the
Afghan troops.
So the idea was,
well,
let's let the private contractor take
that over.
Let's,
let's move that out.
And let's not have the brave men and
women of the US military engaged in
Afghanistan ad Nauseum,
you know,
and this idea is being pushed to some
degree by Erik Prince,
you know,
and he's said things like,
well,
you know,
if,
if you want to keep having this
conversation,
you want to have the conversation 10
years from now,
Friday the military keep doing it,
you know,
or we can be more,
somehow efficient.
And they explained that people who Eric
Princes from Blackwater,
blackwater and yeah,
he came out of a,
of a,
a wealthy Michigan based family.
Betsy devoss the cat or the education
secretary is a sister in the current
administration.
And so he started water and you know,
they uh,
they,
they became sort of the face of right
because they,
they,
they did very well.
It's a private contractor business.
They got good contracts and that was
good.
They had some issues and some problems.
A very controversial,
very controversial.
They sold the business,
renamed it,
then renamed it again,
and Yada,
Yada Yada.
But the point being is that the idea
that somehow you're going to prioritize
this operation in Afghanistan expecting
then I guess here's the thing,
he,
because he said,
well,
it'd be about $10,000,000,000 a year,
which would be a savings on what we
spend now.
You give private contractors,
uh,
you know,
a $10,000,000,000 trough to eat at.
You think they're going to end it
anytime soon,
there's no fucking way.
So if we want this thing to just drag on
ad Nauseum,
fine,
privatized it and put that profit motive
up there and you think somehow it's not
going to happen.
And I can ever to say that as a private
contractor in that had been involved in
it.
Well,
I appreciate your honesty.
Not I just,
it's just,
it's the wrong thing to do.
And if not top of that,
if I guess the,
the,
the overlying,
the 30,000 foot view that I've got is
that if it's important enough for us to
be there,
then that's a military function.
That's,
that's.
Then we have to commit in a way that,
you know,
we're not right now,
we've been in this sort of stalemate
situation right over there and now we're
somewhat surprised.
Are people are surprised at the Taliban
is resurgent,
well,
where the hell did they think they were
going to go?
There's Taliban don't have any place to
go there.
So they're gonna wait us out.
This was entirely predictable that some
and what we're trying to sell them this
pseudo federal democracy,
you know?
Then the Afghan people don't understand
for the most part,
I don't think,
maybe I'm just too cynical,
but they don't understand what the hell
we've been trying to sell them for all
these years.
So this doesn't diminish all the pain
and sacrifice and suffering of all
people that have been out there and the
lives that we've lost.
It doesn't diminish it at all.
What I'm saying is that we need to think
about what's our,
what's our end game,
what's our objective?
So if we're worried now about the
Taliban resurging and Isis,
you know,
kind of coming back in,
well fine,
but let's,
let's say this is our objective and to
meet that objective,
then we're going to need more troops on
the ground and let's see how that plays
out.
I don't think a lot of people are going
to be happy about it.
You don't necessarily do things to make
people happy.
If it's a national security interests.
If we decide that that's in our national
security interest,
then yes,
we need to commit and do it.
But handing it over to a privatized,
you know,
force to me is,
is uh,
is,
is just slightly left of insane.
It doesn't make any sense.
And you know,
it's always easy for people to stand
around and talk tough and say we just
need more troops.
You know?
Well,
I don't know that the objective is
sufficiently clarified to say that we
need more troops.
I haven't heard.
I don't care whether we improve the
literacy rate of the Afghan people by
another percentage point of if we build
another road.
I don't think that's in our national
security interests and so I think we
need to be a little bit more clear about
why we're there,
what we're hoping to accomplish.
At some point we wanted to be there so
that we wouldn't use it as a playground
for terrorists to then develop and plot
and plan and attack the West again,
so maybe the thing that will,
what we should have done was go in
there,
kick the shit out of them that like we
did in Tora Bora and elsewhere,
explained to the remnants of the
government.
If you allow that to happen again,
we're going to come back and we'll do
this again and we're very good at that.
We're very good at strategic operations
and we could have done that and maybe
that's the thing we need to do now.
And then that government's been corrupt
for a very long time.
The Karzai government,
Holy Shit.
They were completely corrupt and yet we
all rallied around cars.
I as if he was because he dressed well.
One of his brother was a heroin.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's awful.
And you know,
in the current government is,
is it any better?
Well,
they're a little more clever at hiding
their corruption,
but it's still exists.
And more importantly,
the tribal society there,
it doesn't really get this idea of,
you know,
a strong central government,
it kind of runs counter to thousands of
years of,
of self governance out there.
But anyway,
so that's,
that's the thing.
So what,
what's he gonna say tonight?
I don't have a clue,
but I think he's,
he does.
He's got limited opera job.
What's it going to take?
We're going to cut and run.
We're going to leave.
That's one option.
We're going to increase the number of US
troops on the ground.
That's one option is right there.
It's a trump,
4,000
more troops to Afghanistan.
Is that,
is that good?
Now here's the thing about when it comes
to operations over there and what are,
what the objectives are.
One of the things that I've been hearing
from people that are in the military
that I know is they say they are happy
that trump is supporting them and that
trump has kind of essentially giving the
reigns,
the military saying,
look,
this is what you guys do.
I'm not going to get in your way.
In fact I'm going to support you,
and there seemed to one of the few
groups
that is fairly universally happy with
his decisions in that regard and with
the people that he's appointed.
I think that's right.
I think law enforcement as well,
I think is it?
Yeah.
If you feel like you've got top cover,
you know,
then you know,
that was one of the problems.
I mean people talked about the art and
we talked about it briefly about the
idea of the sort of the narrative of
sort of a battle between trump and the
intel community where the community had
a problem with the previous
administration because they kept
shifting the goal posts.
They were going to criminally prosecute
people in the agency for engaging in
that interrogation program and rendition
program that had been approved by the
previous administration that you know,
that creates some ill will,
so the fact that you know,
the military and,
and to some degree,
you know,
others and certainly law enforcement of
feel as if they've got this top cover
from the current administration.
That is a good thing.
And if you're,
if you're willing to not politicize all
of this and,
and,
and make every decision related to
national security based on how you think
it's gonna move the polls,
then that's also a good thing.
As long as you're getting good solid
advice and you're consistent in your
decision making process,
all those things are good.
Um,
I don't know enough about trump to know
how,
you know,
he makes those decisions,
but he does have good of Madison's good
pump peo is a good person.
John Kelly,
certainly.
Great Guy.
Mcmaster,
all these people are solid people who in
any other administration would,
you know,
people would be saying,
yeah,
that's great.
You know,
they're very highly regarded,
but it's sort of,
there's this cloud over because it's
trump and people are still not sure how
things play out in that administration,
but if he does listen,
I think yeah,
that's a good thing.
But sending 4,000 more troops,
that's not quite 50 percent on top of
what we've currently got there.
Um,
what does that allow us to do?
Well,
some of those troops are going to have
to be involved in security operations of
the trainers.
Some of those troops are going to have
to be involved in,
you know,
logistical support,
Intel collection support.
So,
you know,
will it make us more effective in
defeating and the short term some of the
pushback from the Taliban and
identifying and taking out more isis
will.
Sure.
Okay.
And then,
and then what?
I guess that's my question.
What,
what,
what are we doing?
What is our objective in Afghanistan
today in 2017?
What is the objective?
I couldn't eloquently,
not that I could add eloquently do shit,
but I couldn't.
I couldn't state what our end game is
there.
I think it's,
I would suppose in a big picture,
it's to create a stable society that
will be a bulwark of some form of
democracy.
Have we ever done that thought?
I mean,
we ever had successfully been involved
in nation building.
We have,
what did you think about,
um,
post World War II,
but that was again at different times.
I mean,
so you can't compare it necessarily,
you know,
chronologically I,
so when we've invaded places or when
we've been a part of like,
look what's going on in Libya,
I mean
we,
we supported that revolution and now
it's a fucking complete disaster and a
terrifying part of the world.
Yeah.
It's a real hot mess and nobody wants to
talk about Libya and we didn't have a
national security interest in Libya and
yet we allow ourselves to get in there.
Why did we do that?
A lot of pressure from the French and
the Italians who did,
and I think we felt it was somehow.
I don't know why,
but maybe there was a feeling as if it
would be easier,
more containable somehow.
But I mean,
shit,
there's more tribal history.
More tribes in Libya than in
Afghanistan.
It's,
you know,
you had to get like 130 some odd tribes
in Olympia.
So another thing that I watched recently
as a,
as a country,
so
watch Qaddafi's death again recently and
watched the whole capture of him and the
whole thing.
It was just fascinating to watch his
brutal evil murderer is dictator.
All the sudden get caught by these
common people.
These rebels,
you know,
like,
outside of his palace and freaking out.
And yeah,
players all fucked up.
And the weird thing is he was,
he was our guy,
he was a dictator.
Renounced.
He had gotten on board for the most part
on sort of a counterterrorism program to
provide assistance or support or at
least not impede A.
I'm not saying it was,
yeah,
it was a,
it was a complete son of a bitch.
But it's interesting isn't it?
The dynamics involved.
And so we decided that it was better to
support the French and Italians and
topple him.
And now you know,
it's,
I mean,
but that's always the case.
You know,
isn't always the case too that we have
these dictators we problem up and then
after a while,
Jesus,
this fucking guy,
we've got to get them out of there.
Like so dumb.
Yeah.
Sort of same and Hussein lasted a long
time in that position.
When you think about the horrific nature
of some of the shit that he did and his
sons did.
Oh yeah.
Sons were completely monsters.
Yeah.
And that's a good point.
I mean,
you know,
and,
but you know,
hey,
how did it,
how did his presence when they were at
odds with Iran,
you know,
how did that help our overall sense of
strategic foreign policy?
So things happen and you don't,
you know,
it's,
you don't get to pick and choose
sometimes I guess maybe you do,
but then it'd be,
it'd be a kind of a strange world,
but you got to deal with sometimes with
the people that are out there and,
and you know,
um,
so it's,
I,
I don't know,
4,000 more troops in Afghanistan.
I,
is that going to somehow solve a
problem?
It's going to,
I suspect,
kick the can down the road.
Again.
It's like Vietnam.
What would you do?
Where did the vehicle have to go?
They had nowhere to go.
It's a totally different situation
though,
isn't it?
Because the Viet Cong really didn't have
any threat to us.
Well,
what I mean is,
is what did we think was gonna Happen?
They were going to outweighed us.
They were going to have glasses.
They were going to say the suffering was
nothing in their minds compared to what
we were going through and how we were
processing.
And so I guess that's what I mean.
You can't.
Yeah,
everything is,
is,
uh,
is relative,
but I mean with this,
um,
what would you do?
Well,
I have,
you were in the situation to call the
shots.
If someone said,
hey,
Mike Baker,
what do we do about Afghanistan?
Yeah.
And you know what,
I'm,
it's,
it,
it.
I'm not saying it's an easy by any
means.
It's a,
it's above my pay grade,
but b,
I think I'm.
Isis creates a different situation
there.
If we hadn't seen isis develop and start
to impact to some degree things that are
going on in Afghanistan,
then I think we could be better off just
saying,
okay,
we're gonna.
Figure out a way to work with the
Taliban.
I mean the Taliban,
I think at this stage of the game could
be contained within Afghanistan without
allowing their place to be used as a
shelter for terrorism.
I say that now caveating saying now
you've got isis and that's a different
kettle of fish because they're at odds
with each other.
So what are we going to do?
I ended up,
you know,
in some weird fashion supporting the
Taliban and their efforts to,
you know,
stamp out isis.
I don't know.
It's a,
it's a,
it's real weird.
Yeah.
This is what we're talking.
Thousands of years of history of failed
efforts in Afghanistan.
And do I think,
do I have the Hubris to think that we
somehow are going to solve this?
No.
So,
you know,
maybe maybe the answer is just find that
point on the curve where you can support
an existing government that you can hold
your nose and live with.
It's,
you know,
that it's corrupt and you know,
but at least they're working in the
counter terrorism realm,
you know,
and they're there supporting those sort
of interests from our perspective.
And yet,
you know,
I don't think we're ever going to get to
that point where we see a stable self
supporting,
you know,
pseudo democratic nation exist there.
I just don't think it's going to happen.
So that's a hugely unsatisfying answer.
But you know,
maybe it's,
maybe it's like pollution.
You do little things,
you know and hope that it helps.
And maybe that's what we're doing here.
You know,
if you just start from the point of view
of saying we're going to create a
bulwark of democracy,
you overwhelmed,
it's never going to happen.
So you don't do anything.
You know,
background.
I,
part of me just,
I hate the idea of leaving,
right?
I mean,
I think a lot of people do who are
living,
we're going to create a vacuum,
right?
Right.
And,
and quite frankly,
that's typically what happens,
you know,
and particularly with isis president
said they would see that and they would
see an opportunity.
Now,
you know,
they,
they're,
they're at odds with the Taliban and the
Taliban is pretty brutal.
Um,
could they handle it on their own,
you know,
meaning,
could they destroy isis on their own?
Who knows?
Maybe,
but it's a,
it certainly complicates the situation.
But now,
especially if we just decide to switch
somehow or another support isis now,
that's never going to happen.
Whenever.
No,
I mean,
excuse me,
the Taliban,
their battle against Isis could see
that.
I could see elements of the Taliban
saying,
look,
we just want to self govern.
Right?
Okay,
we get it.
But you're not going to
imagine a scenario where the United
States would support the Taliban because
they were at war with Isis.
Taliban could soften their stance on
some things.
We reached some sort of common ground.
Well look,
we're kind of on the same side with Iran
against Isis right?
And we're not supporting Iran in a way.
We are in a sense that we're,
we're trying to kill the same people.
Right?
So who would have thought that,
you know,
four or five years ago.
So that's how nutty Isis says.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Everybody can agree.
Everybody get a great.
That's the one group that everybody can
agree on.
Um,
but yeah,
I don't know.
It's interesting.
So that's what the president's going to
talk about this evening.
4,000 more troops.
I,
you know,
he could have said we're gonna leave and
the people that hate trump would be up
in arms.
You could say we're going to add 40,000
troops are going to be up in arms.
You could say we're going to give it
over to the private contractors.
They'd be up in arms.
It doesn't really matter.
So there's going to be a lot of
opposition to this regardless.
Um,
if there's a clear defined mission with
an end game,
fine.
I just haven't heard.
I don't know what that is.
And maybe they,
maybe they've said it and I just haven't
seen it.
Well,
it seems like the only way we're ever
going to get peace and harmony in the
world is if there's no fifth world,
fourth world,
third world or second world.
Just one first world.
Everybody has like suburban problems.
Yeah.
Is that even possible?
No.
I mean,
I never society where everybody's on the
same footing.
Impossible.
A universal basic income and a cross the
world and get rid of law enforcement.
Doing exactly.
No everywhere.
I don't think that's it.
Yeah,
it's not gonna happen and I,
that's so disheartening for people
though to a guy like you as so many
years of experience in intelligence
agencies that you would say that there's
nothing that could ever be done that
would give peace in the world.
Like generations from now,
we're still going to be dealing with the
same issues.
Maybe if the chemist can figure out a
way to get us all so next to see mean
that's going to solve it.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know.
You know,
it's,
it's the way it is.
It's human nature.
And um,
I,
you know,
we have,
we go through periods of pace,
you can go through periods of prosperity
and during those periods it kind of
helps to lift everybody up and they get
to a certain level that they didn't
imagine before.
There's still trailing.
But are we ever going to get to a point
where we're all,
you know,
we're all the same.
I don't,
I,
I mean I hate great,
but I don't see it.
Here's the perfect xenical
the United States in Germany,
right?
We were at war in the 19 forties and now
we're absolutely a piece.
I mean this in Germany is prosperous and
it's a great country and everything's
great.
I mean,
I would wonder what would have to take
place for this to be a worldwide thing
where the rest of the world sort of
rises up to an adequate level of
civilization and we no longer engage and
the potential global war
that we're all looking at right now.
And we're really looking at the
possibility with Russia and with North
Korea and all these different players.
There could be some sort of a twisted
world war three going on.
Russia is,
Russia is punching over its weight.
I mean at the end of the day,
Russia's got to GDP,
you know,
equivalent to a midsize EU country.
Right.
I mean,
so they just,
you know,
at Putin is very clear.
He wants to rebuild the Soviet Union to
some degree in some fashion.
Right.
And he's been,
he's done it through some territory.
It doesn't do energy policy through
meddling like they always do,
but.
So,
you know,
I don't think Russia,
but to your point,
yeah,
as with the US Germany,
could we see a,
a way that the US and Iran for example,
could find common ground and suddenly 40
years from now be at peace and not only
a piece but supporting each other's
economy and you know,
have that sort of interaction.
And
I dunno,
I don't think so.
Thanks.
So damn.
Can I pour some coffee and I'm good.
I'm just thinking.
I'm just like,
just at a certain point in time,
it just,
it's very frustrating to think that.
I guess the pace of progress is so
incredibly slow.
When you look back in history,
this is probably the safest time to be
alive ever.
So there's been some progress from Roman
times to today.
There's obviously been some worldwide
progress.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah,
yeah.
Longevity and stamping out disease and
all the rest of those things.
Where is like,
you know,
for what it's worth,
it's a great time to be alive and people
that are walking around everyday trying
to find a reason to be offended or
finding that it is because there's no
real conflict that they have these
issues that the words aren't coming over
the border to know,
to,
uh,
to rape and pillage,
you know,
Great Depression.
There's food will display easy to find.
They did find the plague that did found
the P bionic plague on some ticks,
right?
Yep.
Where was that?
Was that in Arizona?
I figured it was God Damn Arizona.
It's a response to Joe,
our pio,
getting arrested.
Everybody's mad.
I wonder if that's what it wasn't there.
Some talk about trump pardoning him.
Yeah.
What does he get?
His bubonic plague and Arizona Fleas
found carrying the infectious disease.
There you go.
Wonderful Guy.
You know,
and that's where it's going to be.
It's not going to be.
This is my,
for what it's worth.
I put this along with my big pussy
theory,
but it's not going to be the North
Koreans,
you know,
firing off a missile or whatever it's
gonna be this idea.
It's gonna be a pandemic.
Something that we didn't quite see
coming mutation of a,
of a disease or something that because I
do believe in the idea that nature takes
care of its own eventually,
you know,
just like a deer herd or whatever.
And eventually the overpopulation issue
becomes a concern and that's how the
earth tends to reset itself.
You know,
that is always how it works.
Yeah.
That would suck.
But another reason to be in Idaho,
bubonic plague and they have three human
cases in New Mexico that article said,
and then they found it in fleas in
Arizona.
Yeah.
Well everybody goes to your doctor.
Well survive the winter.
So Idaho,
what else has been going on?
What else?
You tell me
the inside track.
Yeah,
well there is that a man with a suit
coat on.
I know I get that and what?
What I have in here also as a pocket
square,
I can pull it up.
I pulled that out when I do a TV
interview,
I pulled up a pocket square and just to
get a little classier way how people
tend to think you know what you're
talking about when you have a Hanky.
I've learned that from a Guy Ritchie
explained the pocket square to me.
Yeah,
he schooled me in it,
so it's not something that I was working
on and developing.
This is his theory,
his theory,
but he is a very well educated and very
well thought out in regards to his
choice of suits and a man wearing a well
tailored suit.
Tim,
is he still married to Madonna?
We got rid of the check a long time ago.
I remember,
but he had a kid with her.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
I remember Madonna as soon as she
started seeing Guy Richie.
I was living in England at the time and
she just suddenly out of nowhere had a
British accent.
I love it,
love it.
People do.
That's fantastic.
I love that.
I love when white people talk like black
people.
I love.
Um,
it's my favorite or a Chinese guy
talking like black guy that's even
better.
Chinese guy now.
I what?
Have you heard that?
I've seen it.
I've seen it many times.
I'm a big fan of a trans racial,
like people that think they're the wrong
race.
Yes.
That's a new thing.
It's one of the few trans things you can
mock still.
Can you mock it?
Yes.
Okay.
Letting it go.
He said.
Well that'd be,
that would be Rachel Dolezal,
the Naacp in spokane.
That's right.
And the identified with Shaun King.
Yeah,
he's another one,
but he denies it.
He says that,
uh,
it's actually,
it's all that everyone is wrong.
His Mom,
his dad,
his birth certificate people,
he knows,
they all lied to them.
Uh,
they're line everybody else and only he
knows.
Oh well it says his mom had an affair
with a light skin black man or
something.
Somebody who knows.
Exactly.
It's just I can't,
I can't find enough energy given
everything else that's going to be
offended by very much frankly.
I just don't get.
I like people to live their own lives.
If you are happy,
God bless you.
Just be happy.
I'm way more amused that I am ever
offended by things like that.
I'm amused.
That's a good way to put it.
Yeah,
that's a good way.
That's a good way to say it.
You're more amusing than offended.
I just.
Do you know Rachel Dolezal the trick
from spokane because she,
uh,
got in trouble,
you know,
because everyone's mad at her.
She changed her name legally to the
blackest name the world has ever known
with young Jamie.
Pull it up.
Pull that name up.
W.
This is a,
it's a wonderful name and I would
encourage anyone that wants to be
transformational to do the game.
The same thing.
AndK ,
e,
c h I a.
I don't know how you say that.
The catchy a marree.
Dr. Lo,
that's her new name.
Ready?
Here we go again.
Nick catchy a marree.
D'Angelo d I a l l O hm.
I liked the description that they give
her.
She's a former civil rights activist.
Enough.
Oh,
well,
I guess because she was fired,
but former Afrikanas studies instructor.
What's Afrikaana?
She decided to give up the civil rights
activist thing.
Hm.
Yeah.
Silly goose.
But it was great when she had like a
fro,
like look at her over there with that.
Yeah.
Full white family orange.
Spray Tan from Lincoln County,
Montana.
Little Ruth Ann's girl.
But she feels like she identifies with
black people more.
She likes the culture more and you know,
there's always been people that like the
culture more and talk less.
Sure that they're a part of the culture.
You don't,
you don't say you are.
Yeah.
That's the new thing though,
isn't that a love of creating and
aren't.
They aren't the people that are offended
by the idea of appropriating.
Like if I opened a Mexican restaurant,
people would be offended because I
shouldn't do that.
I should just,
uh,
you know,
and I know you do.
I know black people that were furious at
her and I know other people that are
also black that were laughing
hysterically at it.
They thought it was what it was.
I think it really doesn't affect you.
It's preposterous and not only that,
don't be infuriated by the fact that she
got caught.
I mean she's,
I mean this is not like having any undue
influence.
This is all ridiculous.
No,
exactly.
And that.
And also again,
it's this idea that people are walking
around looking for reasons to be
offended.
Yeah.
And it just seems exhausting.
It's like everything.
And so I don't,
I don't know how people do it.
I don't know why they do it.
Maybe they just don't have enough going
on in their lives,
have enough objectivity and they get
caught up in the momentum of being
pissed off about something,
but the cultural appropriation or
pretending you're something like,
look at how many fucking people pretend
they're native American because it makes
them seem more spiritual.
Jesus,
that's always been an issue.
Yeah.
Yeah,
there is.
Elizabeth,
why was just trying to remember her
name?
Is she gonna I wonder if she's going to
run in 20,
20.
It's going to be a problem.
Yeah.
The allied and said you were part native
American to get some sort of
scholarship.
That's right.
Harvard,
wasn't it?
Oh,
look at that.
Yeah.
I will say this.
The world is so funny.
After a,
when,
uh,
when we went into Iraq in 2003,
early 2003,
um,
people started looking at the business
opportunities that rock.
Right.
And I remember there was that whole
idea,
excuse me,
that there was gonna be all sorts of
business opening up in Iraq because I
don't know why they were thinking.
But um,
so then it became people looking for
contracts,
government contracts,
commercial sector contracts to do
business in Iraq.
And so the idea was suddenly there was a
mad rush to open up a minority owned and
veteran owned and
women owned businesses.
So the idea was if you had a,
like an annual Indian,
you know,
Eskimo who was supposedly in charge of
your business that gave you extra points
when you were weighed in the bid for a
contract that you were going for.
So there became this cottage industry,
you know,
much like the casino business of trying
to find tribes that you can represent in
order for them to end to open up a and
you're creating essentially a tribe to
have a casino.
It gives them a certain advantages
which.
So it's,
it's an interesting,
it's an interesting world we live in.
Well the native American casino business
is very weird in that regard and also
that a lot of people in these areas,
because there are certain percentage and
I think it's as little as one slash 16th
native American,
you can get a check.
So like if,
if the casinos raking in the cash,
the people that are a part of that tribe
all get free money.
Yeah.
So these casinos are just generating
like fucking billions of dollars a year
that just because someone,
some of them require,
some of them are cow,
you know,
marginal.
But,
but uh,
you know,
there are a number of them that do,
do very well.
And you know,
wasn't for some of these.
I don't know about you,
but some of the.
I tell you what,
I want to be depressed,
go to,
you know,
there's certain Indian reservations in
this country that are just awful.
Oh my God,
I love her.
Poverty is just alcoholism down and,
and.
Yeah,
exactly.
Substance Abuse and lack of opportunity,
lack of educational facilities for the
kids and that's just not,
that's not right.
We should do.
We should be far better than that.
There should not be a native American
foundations are very strange when you
think about like how long ago it was,
these tribes,
people were roaming the earth and
nomadic fashion and living the life they
did before the Europeans came and that
now they've become this segmented part
of our population that's sort of a part
of America but has their own kind of
like nation inside of a nation.
And it was weird rules like the way they
have it up in Canada,
they call them first nation people,
but in candidates real weird in regards
to wildlife,
like I don't know if you know how it
works up there,
but they can shoot anything they want
all year round and they have it that way
in Washington state as well with elk
hunt elk all year round.
The rules are so different things the
same way.
They use spotlights for Moose.
So like they drive at night with four by
fours.
The Moose see the spotlight,
they freeze,
they belong away with high powered
rifles and they can kill him as many as
they want all year round the same.
If we used to go spotlighting kangaroos.
I lived in Australia when I was younger,
were stationed in England,
Australia.
I've lived in a lot of places,
but I'm now in my.
I'm in my last place now.
Idaho.
I'm not,
I've never moved.
But um,
yeah we used to go in Australia,
worked on,
lived on a sheep station out there,
massive property and we get into the,
of the truck with the spotlights.
And you go out and those kangaroos are
hard as shit to hit.
They are tough.
Haunting.
No.
You guys doing that for population
control?
Many of them,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean this would be delicious.
You know,
it can be,
you know,
depending on how old they are and which
high.
But um,
the uh,
the tail is actually the tastiest part.
Why Kangaroo tail?
Yeah.
I don't know about all that,
but no,
I don't mean the ass.
I mean the tail tail because it
balances.
So I've seen the idea you go in real
life.
Yeah.
So,
but anyway,
they are hard to hit.
They are completely unpredictable in
their movement and they just uh,
and they move fast and they,
uh,
they jump the fences,
they can clear.
It's impressive.
I know why I'm talking about,
we played a video inviting these massive
herds or packs or whatever you call
them,
of kangaroos roaming across the field.
Like some people have no idea what the
numbers are.
You know,
I have friends that live in Australia
and they tell me like there's places
that are just infested and there's
nothing they can do.
They don't know what to do.
So they,
they literally have to gun them down
because there's no predators.
It is.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
I mean when he got dingoes not going to
bring down a,
you know,
a,
a kangaroo,
good luck.
Feral cat and you know,
I mean,
but it's.
Yeah.
So this,
they just,
they're all over the place.
I'm great little animal.
So yeah,
they're kind of cute and they're tasty.
Know,
look at these fuckers go bouncing all
over the place.
A kangaroo call starts that Jesus
Christ.
So many of them.
And Oh,
people were upset.
I guess people were upset at the
kangaroo call was going to have that.
Well,
uh,
Ellen got stuck in a fence.
That's not good.
Yeah.
I mean whenever you have an animal that
doesn't have any sort of a natural
predator and they can just free free
ball it.
Exactly,
yeah.
That's what they,
they and Australia is such an
interesting place.
You know,
every time they introduce a species to
try to solve a problem that's pcs takes
off.
Yeah.
It just,
and it's,
it's never ending.
I was trying to explain to someone the
other day about the cats there.
Yeah.
That they,
they hunt cats like,
like what we think of as a pet.
And they were like,
why?
And I'm like,
listen,
I know it doesn't seem right,
but the feral cat population is just run
out of control.
Like we did a podcast once we pulled up
the feral cat population in America and
what it does that they killed billions
of birds and rodents in America.
Yeah.
And someone was like,
no,
that can't be right.
I'm like,
listen,
they,
the scientists who did the study of
shocked cats are fucking murderers.
Yeah.
And we had a cat,
a great cat named Charlie who's now
died.
Um,
but he was a,
he was not to a captain most part,
but he would,
uh,
he would kill chipmunks and he would lay
the chipmunks out in a row to get
offering.
Yeah.
And he was incredibly efficient.
We try to keep them indoors.
But you know,
the guy,
he just wanted to be outside killing
something,
so just fun time and then come in and
you open up a nice fresh can of cat food
for them.
Like thanks dad.
He's got a little bit of chip monck in
his tooth.
Uh,
yeah.
But the feral cats.
Yeah.
In,
uh,
in the,
in the ranch.
I mean,
you'd be out repairing fences or
something and yeah,
you just kinda get off or they'd spook
the horses or you'd get to put your hand
down to Pixar and Bob,
they just come out of nowhere and
they're just,
they're bastards.
Yeah.
They're not kitty,
kitty cats.
Hello Kitty.
Yeah,
they're like a wild small Predator
that's extremely vicious.
And you know,
they killed things all the time though.
The feral cat problem in the United
States is insignificant in comparison to
what it does in Australia though.
Australia,
they have devastated ground nesting
birds and all sorts of other species
because they're an invasive species and
there's nothing.
Again,
there's nothing really good dingoes
maybe,
but you know,
that's that then I can't get a
deputation is now.
So it didn't go it.
My baby,
where you live is fascinating because
you've got,
you've got everything up there,
you got grizzly bears.
Yeah.
You gotTa,
you gotta get a healthy grizzly
population.
I have a buddy who went black bear
hunting up there and they could not find
black bears.
They found board grizzlies.
Yeah.
They start grizzly after grizzly after
grizzly.
It's amazing.
I mean,
it is,
and it is,
it's such a good thing.
And when you see the sort of the health
of the,
of the wildlife population and just,
it makes you feel really good,
you know,
and it's,
it's hard to explain.
I mean,
people.
I was up in yellowstone and,
and uh,
once again,
I'm always amazed at how people interact
with wildlife when they're not used to
it.
Right?
And Yellowstone is probably the best
place to see that happen because there's
so many tourists during the busy time of
year and they'll just say there's no
regard for the fact that it's a wild
animal.
Right?
And even the Bison and the price will
kill you in a hot second if they get
pissed off and you'll get these
tourists,
it'll get out of that car and you know,
and,
uh,
the husband will be taking a picture and
telling his wife to get a little bit
closer,
get closer right now.
Maybe he's doing it deliberately,
right?
But,
uh,
but it's,
it's an amazing thing.
Hey,
she looks fine and,
uh,
but it is,
it's an amazing.
That's another place for people if they,
if they haven't been to yellowstone,
go to yellowstone.
What seems like a zoo to people,
you know,
you see these gigantic,
furry star wars looking things out
there.
I mean,
that's what a buffalo it looks like when
you see it real life.
Is that real?
Yeah.
So they're so big.
They are,
they have massive.
And then we were in,
we were there and at one point was,
it was getting to be twilight and um,
came around a corner and I was with a
couple of the rangers and,
and uh,
there was a vehicle stopped.
It was a,
what do they call it?
A minivan.
And it was stopped on the side of the
road and there were half a dozen people
out of this minivan and they work all
kinds of fussing about,
you know,
and it just a little bit in the field
they're on the side and think what are
they doing?
And then it became clear that there was
little calf out there.
Oh,
little
license calf.
It was gotten separated from the herd
and I guess they had seen it,
but it now you could hear it.
It was kinda over there bleeding.
And,
and,
uh,
they wanted to get it.
They wanted to wrap it up.
Meaning bleeding.
Yeah.
They make noise.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Not,
not bleeding.
Um,
although that,
that was probably the next step in this
evolution,
um,
was uh,
they were,
they were trying to figure out how to
round it up and get it back to its.
And the Rangers,
you know,
said,
okay,
here we go again.
And,
and they said,
look,
this happens.
Unfortunately people don't realize it's
nature.
So they had to get out.
And I stood there and listened while
they explain these people,
look,
this calf is somebody's dinner now,
you know,
it's going to be,
found and devoured by other forces of
nature out.
Luckily wolves.
Yeah.
And uh,
and there's a wolf population is coming
back up there,
which is great.
And so these people were horrified.
They were,
they were amazed at the rangers wouldn't
do something like,
I guess catch the calf,
put it in the back of the truck and
drive it to the ticket to the zoo,
take it to the zoo or take it to the
herd or take it home and bottle feed it.
It's not much you can do.
And most likely if it's mother left it
behind,
maybe there's something wrong with the
mother as well.
Yeah.
I mean,
who knows what the,
what the reasoning was behind it.
But it was,
it was interesting.
It was a good lesson.
But that place is that the park system
anyway,
I think we've talked about that before.
It's just astounding in this amazing.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And the natural,
uh,
the,
the uh,
rather the national parks that,
uh,
that we have,
in,
in Idaho in particular,
you guys have a lot of public ally
wilderness,
uh,
you know,
into the Frank Church.
Wildernesses insane the size.
Um,
I've read a really good book called the
big burn if anybody's looking for a book
to pick up and read,
it's about this massive forest fire that
took place mostly in Idaho and it was,
um,
during the course of,
uh,
of Teddy Roosevelt's time.
And it also,
it also covers Teddy Roosevelt,
um,
and his efforts and the way that he got
turned on to conservation.
Um,
and the beginnings of the firefighting,
you know,
um,
profession a forest fires.
And it's a fascinating read.
I mean,
you think about it,
people are going to go,
really,
I'm going to read a book about a big
forest fire,
but it's,
it's incredible.
And they weave in the history and the
time of the administration and how they
were declaring parks and what they were
doing and how they tried to tackle this
fire and what that meant for future
conservation term.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's a fascinating book,
so it's called the big burn.
I'm drawing a blank on who wrote it,
but if anybody's out there listening and
wants to book,
pick it up,
how did they try to stop a fire back
then?
Especially a massive wildfire,
you know,
doing a lot of the same things that they
do now,
right?
Cutting lines and breaks and trying to
deprive it of fuel,
feeding it back on itself.
Um,
it was,
uh,
just manpower,
just sheer manpower and trying to um,
and you know,
putting up
the smoke towers and,
and,
you know,
creating a,
back then that's what they were doing.
They were just out in the middle of
nowhere.
You try to,
you try to space out these,
these,
um,
outposts,
these little points on a top of the
mountains where you can identify smoke
and try to catch it.
You know,
like if you've got an electrical storm,
boom,
then all of a sudden you see some smoke
and you realize you probably got to
start a fire.
You want to get on it as quick as
possible.
So then nowadays you'll call and the
smoke jumpers and they'll go in and
that's an insane job,
um,
to try to contain it,
put it out,
but there's always been debate.
What do you do?
Do you let it burn,
do you,
how do you,
how do you deal with it?
Depends on the weather forecast as well.
Weather forecast and it,
part of it was politics and it was me
back then in Roosevelt's time,
it was all the timber barons,
right.
And the mining barons and the railroad
barons and you know,
they weren't interested in,
in Roosevelt's idea of claiming land for
the public.
Um,
and so,
you know,
it,
it was so fascinating.
It's a fascinating read.
And again,
sort of go back to that same thing that
we talked about it before,
how did this nation could cobbled
together and how did it end up looking
the way it looked?
And Roosevelt had some real vision.
He really did.
I mean,
we're so thankful we should be so
thankful because of that vision.
We have this incredible national park
system and all this public land.
I talked to a wildlife biologist who
said that that's one of the reasons why
we have all these issues with like bark
beetles and all these different,
a dead tree issues that when we get a
forest fire today,
it's like so out of control because we
don't allow these burns to take place,
which they do naturally in nature.
Right?
Yeah.
And that's part of it because you can
imagine what happens if you,
if,
if you don't do that,
you develop the fuel over a long period
of time,
uh,
and then you get a devastating fire.
And,
and also apparently the carbon from
those trees burning is actually good for
the ground.
The soil it didn't know it is,
it's very,
it's the ability of the land to bounce
back.
We see it in not all the time.
And you get up in Montana and in other
parts,
parts of Wyoming,
you see how quickly.
Yeah,
the environment can,
can bounce back.
And how often do you see like wolves and
grizzlies and stuff like that where you
are
wolves more than than grizzlies.
The grizzlies is still.
Yeah,
they'll still,
they,
you know,
they'll try to keep to themselves.
Um,
but,
but you're seeing a ton of elk.
Yeah.
More wolves.
We had a lot of.
Everybody's got coyotes,
so they're so resilient.
They are like the cockroach of the
Mammal,
you know?
Yeah,
they're pretty incredible.
Um,
but uh,
it's,
yeah,
it's uh,
I,
I'd say if,
if you're,
you know,
if you're looking at,
um,
an accessible trip and I get to ask this
all the time,
what would you do?
Where would you go if you had like two
weeks to take the kids and drive him
somewhere?
I would just point the car towards a
Utah,
Idaho,
Montana,
Wyoming and just,
yeah,
just head up there and then just see
what you can see.
You know,
you've got plenty of opportunity to,
a tremendous number of excellent parks
and you know,
show the kids something different.
Yeah.
Just let them understand these fats.
Vast swaths of land that it just open
wilderness.
Take the electronics away to give me
your.
I bet.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Don't hide those in the trunk.
God,
we're starting to get the kids all
start.
I'll start school tomorrow and they know
as soon as the school year starts,
that's it.
They don't get as much electronics now.
Yeah,
no more.
I mean,
unless they have homework or something
like that,
it's just too easy to find like escape
in that from life and that life is
critical for young minds and even being
bored.
I was reading something about the power
of boredom and how important it is for
creativity that is kids today are kids
that are never bored.
They never have to think of something to
do.
They can always just look at their phone
or look at the TV and it never activates
that part of their brain where they're
searching and thinking.
That's really interesting.
I hadn't thought about that,
but you're right.
Because we tend to plan everything for
them.
Okay.
Now you got to go to your uh,
whatever your hockey lesson.
Go to Lacrosse,
now it's going to be baseball,
now you've got chess club or whatever
the hell you doing.
Um,
yeah,
you're right.
And,
and it's also kind of goes back to that
idea that we use to manage these things
for ourselves.
Right.
And so kids would go out and they would
organize their own teams and I worry
about that too.
I mean,
I like a God,
you know,
just the ability for kids to meet up at
a playground and say,
okay,
we're going to end,
you know,
maybe it happens and I'm making too much
of this,
but we can't have that because bobby
keeps getting picked last and it's
terrible for his self esteem.
Meanwhile,
at Bobby's going to become a software
coder that makes the ai that runs the
world.
That's right.
Now that's what happens,
right?
All the chickens get.
Bobby.
Bobby gets passed and bobby becomes mark
Zuckerberg or Elon Musk.
I just said chicks am my lead to say
chicks,
chicks.
I was just like,
you can still mock transracial people.
Okay.
Games all the broads.
That's where it gets tricky.
All abroad,
you're going to want bobby.
They've coder broads a weird one,
isn't it?
Because they're not really that broad.
Yeah.
I caught that happen in dames.
We're not really private dix from the 19
thirties.
So I guess what Dane was.
Dane was I,
I don't know.
I think of the Maltese Falcon or
something like that.
Game a private.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
I mean they would say they would say
yeah,
the dame know walked in.
My life changed,
but broads is a weird one because it's
fun to say because it's like a bunch of
guys.
It's fucking broad.
Broad.
I love the saying that I feel like I
should be smoking a cigarette.
I'm saying bring a cigar for sure.
Yeah.
Martini.
There's not a whole lot of things that
chicks can say about us like that
though.
Like Bros.
It's sorta like how black people never
had a replacement word for the n word
for white people.
LIke honky just does not have any
negative impact.
It doesn't work,
but like it's a throwback.
It's a real historical throwback.
Honky doesn't work.
Remember the last time I heard anybody
she trashed like whatever.
That doesn't hurt.
Yeah.
But like broads is a funny derogatory
term for what women don't.
I guess burrows they have bros douche
bags.
Yeah.
That's probably,
that's probably what more more to the
point.
Frozen perspective.
White oriented though bros are always
white people.
He never say a bunch of bros and it's
black eyes.
I didn't know that.
I didn't know what jamie.
If you're younger,
you'd be a fuck boy.
Oh,
that's true.
That's called a fuckboy.
Right.
But that's a lot of people to like black
people.
Like that's ian edwards has that
hilarious bit.
It's a.
It's everywhere.
It's universal though.
It's across the board.
So we can all agree on fuckboy.
Yeah.
I don't know what that means.
I don't.
I don't mean like a derogatory term.
Okay.
Yeah,
because I mean in some circles,
who knows?
Maybe that's a good thing.
I don't know.
Bright cougar wants to fuck.
Boy.
It's like speaking italian wrong.
I'm sure I'm not getting it right.
You got it right.
Because if you're in a situation where
you're like an old broad who's got a lot
of money and you want some young.
Fuck boy.
Yeah.
He wants a car,
right?
Yeah.
It's good man.
Going to fuck boy is not going to sell
for a prius.
You had some personal trainer at
kroger's.
Got to spend some cash.
Yeah.
She's got to get him a ferrari.
Sorta like how the guy who owned the uh,
was it the clippers,
that guy,
the old man.
What the fuck's his name?
Donald sterling.
Sterling memory had that broad.
He got her.
He had a broad right.
He did have a broad,
broad.
Yeah.
And he got her like a ferrari and a
bentley and bought her a condo.
But the broads used to work in the steno
pool.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
the ones in the steno pool and the
office environment back in the sixties.
I know for full.
Yeah,
because if you needed to apply,
you know,
you'd have to,
you'd have to get,
you know,
marge to come up from the steno pool and
she would take notes and then,
you know,
do the letter or whatever the paper and
you'd post it in the mail and that's how
you get business done.
And that's aLert.
Whoa.
That's a standard thing.
You gotta look at that.
There's a lot of frauds.
And that steno pool.
If I was one of those [inaudible] I'd be
like,
I'd rather be a hooker.
I gotta take this.
Some dudes in there though,
probably not be a steno pool now.
Maybe just.
Oh,
okay.
Guys there,
they allowed them to work with women
back then.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
Steno pools to cubicles and back again.
Wow.
Fuck all that to you.
Learned about standup pools.
I learned about.
Fuck boys.
That's a trap.
And a half though,
isn't it?
Imagine working in a place like that.
I was like,
what?
Where are you going from here?
And the other one was the,
uh,
the,
the telephone command center.
Can we take that picture up on the upper
top colored picture?
Look right there.
The one with the color in it.
No one with the girl holding up the
sign.
Oh,
look at that.
Swimming in the steno pool by lynn
peril.
Oh god.
A retro guy to make it in the office.
Fuck.
Look at that.
Big of that modern office equipment.
They're there in the lower left hand
corner.
Gives you a sense of the date of that
book.
No more writing with a crayon.
See,
nowadays,
a key office environment is much more
dangerous now.
I think it's much more fraught with
potential for hazards and landmines.
Look at that.
That recording device there.
Boy,
let me do that thing.
See,
so he was talking and to transcribe all
that.
Is that what was going on?
Like a dictaphone?
What is with the guy with a bowler hat?
This is a movie which was like a spy or
something.
Oh yeah,
that's it.
Because you know,
we used to wear a dress like that.
I don't know if you could.
You can zoom in on that,
but that was actually.
We would get that after we completed
training,
they would actually give us an outfit
like that,
the entire weight,
the bowler hat and like,
that's nice.
And then we would set off on our
adventures lakes.
What's that new movie?
The kingsmen.
So what it is,
bunch of spies out there kicking ass.
I have not seen that.
Teaching you deadly skills.
Like how to kill people at upenn.
They would teach you life skills.
Like how to use regular
field expediency.
Yeah,
I mean it's like knowing how to fire for
whatever weapon you pick up off the
ground.
It's just simply knowing you know,
what,
what would work and most of it's common
sense,
right?
I mean in terms of what would actually
do the job,
but yeah,
I mean it's,
it's just,
it's just a field expediency,
which is good.
Was it in madison?
Practical information.
Be polite,
be professional,
and have a plan to kill everyone.
You meet madIson madison,
who?
I thought you were talking about.
John madison.
James madison.
Wow.
They were tough son of a bitches.
Be like then.
No.
So mad.
It's okay.
Mad dog mattis.
Love to say mad dog,
didn't he?
Yes.
He was absolutely in love with mad dog
with that name.
Well,
he liked it because he had his own life.
Hitman.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know.
What do you think this is going?
Do you think he's in for four years and
not anymore polite.
Be professional,
but have a plan to kill everyone.
You meet madison.
that's the kind of guy you want in that
position.
You want to go with things like that and
anybody who doesn't understand that well
good.
I'm glad you're not in that position.
Yeah,
because.
And that goes back to Afghanistan.
We were talking about what's the end
game if you're going to do this,
don't let it,
let's not draw,
you know,
it kind of lets not do this thing where
we're dying by paper cuts or whatever
you wanna call it.
And I just.
And that's kind of where it's been.
I just feel like we've been in a Holding
pattern for years now when it comes to
Afghanistan without really knowing where
we're going or where we want to be when
we get to the end of that road.
And you know.
So if somebody like madison and people
in general in the military,
I understand if you're going to do
something,
you do it to win,
that's your objective.
And I worry that,
well maybe 40,000 troops is not exactly
doing it to when it's doing what they
feel they can get away with.
And I don't know where that gets us.
At the end of the day,
this whole tRump thing is getting
weirder and weirder with every day.
So to even predict where we could be six
months from now,
forget about four years from now or
three and a half years from now.
I think that when you look at some of
the stuff that he does,
you really have to wonder
about his mental health and I don't,
I don't say that like,
you know,
there's a lot of people that are saying
that I think because,
because they would like to think that
he's mentally incompetent and it became
convenIent for their argument.
But when,
when I read that,
I don't know what agency it was,
was trying to get the ip addresses of
people that visited an anti trump
website.
Did you hear about that?
Like sessions is working on.
That's,
that's insane.
Because I could have visited that site
if somebody sent me a link.
You got to see this crazy anti-trump
site.
that doesn't mean I'm a part of that
community or anything like that.
You can't get ip addresses for him.
Someone who visits things online either
side.
Anytime it does.
I don't care which administration it is.
I mean,
you can argue.
yeah,
it's just the potential for abuse of
power.
I've always agreed with that idea.
I'm a small government person,
so the potential for abuse of power is
always there and needs to be monitored.
Potential catastrophic.
Yeah,
because as soon as people lose
confidence and that's one of the biggest
issues with trump as a president,
if people lose confidence in the
institution,
like one of the things that was very
disturbing to a lot of people was that
when he had those russians over and he
was explaining how isis is thinking
about using laptops as bombs and they're
like,
jesus fucking christ,
this is top secret shit.
You're noT supposed to say that because
then this could potentially compromise
people that are embedded in isis that
are distributing this information.
Like you have a bunch of people that
you're giving up this information.
There's a trickle down effect and it
also diminishes the potential for people
to trust the office person running all
the time.
You see that?
I mean the previous administration had
problems where they sort of in their
desire to rush to the podium to declare
a victory and something.
There was
a disregard for sources and methods of
disregard for the importance of
occasionally,
you know,
secrets are good on,
uh,
in,
in many cases when it comes to intel
operations,
you want again,
you want checks and Balances.
That's,
I completely get that.
And of course people are losing their
mindset going,
I can't believe it's cia guy talking
about checks and balances because,
you know,
I'm sure he doesn't believe it,
but it's true.
The place you know for that is in the
committees and up on capital hill where
you're supposed to have an engaged,
aggressively curious,
inquisitive.
I'm operation up there between the
various committees that are supposed are
charged with overseeing,
you know,
the work of the intel community.
And,
and oftentimes they do know exactly
what's going on.
They just play this game where they
disavow any knowledge when it looks like
this political blow back.
there's a fairly well worn path between
langley as an example in capitol hill
for the briefings telling people this is
what's going on,
this is what's happening.
And then,
you know,
the general unwritten understanding is,
they're going to be assholes.
If it becomes politically expedient to
do so,
they'll disavow that they knew about it
and they'll demand in,
you know,
and it's just so a game that gets played
sometimes.
But um,
yeah,
I think,
um,
I think that it's,
it's,
it's hard to say I've got,
I've got friends who are very,
a hard left and they're convinced that,
that trump's on his way out in the not
too distant future.
I think that's a lot of wishful
thinking,
but I don't think he's gonna make it for
years.
I might be wrong.
It just doesn't seem like it.
I think he's also incredibly resilient
though,
because he is,
he's unusual in that regard.
He's also a guy though that wants love
and respect and wants to be a winner.
Like everything he does it in regards to
business decisions mean he,
he'll take something personally himself
to declare a victory.
Right.
And you got to wonder whether or not we
would put someone in position,
you know,
to say like,
the fake news is so out to get him to.
What we've done is we've created a
structure that's the best people for the
job.
And then I'm going to concentrate on
business and helping them from the
outside.
you could escape and have some sort of
escape route.
There's not.
Again,
it sometimes seems as if there's no
grownups in charge of the messaging that
comes out of the white house.
Right.
And that's Been the case since day one
basically.
And part of it is,
you know,
maybe people say,
well,
that's the way he likes to play.
He likes to play people off of each
other anD he likes the chaos.
And they,
well,
you know why he never ran a big
organization.
People imagined or thought if they
didn't,
if they,
you know,
if you didn't spend any time up in New
York and having watched the trump
organization for years and years and
years,
if he hadn't done that,
then you imagine it to be this massive
organization.
Well it's not,
it's always been kind of a family
business.
Right.
And it's just so the chaos that's
around,
that shouldn't be a surprise.
What is a surprise is that,
You know,
he wasn't,
he wasn't sharp enough for what I know
what it is.
They tend to understand the importance
of inserting the discipline in there and
at least if nothing else,
being consistent and disciplined with
the messaging that comes out and just
quit the fucking tweeting.
People say,
oh,
I love it.
That's what makes him him for people.
It's an entertainment that,
you know,
it's a,
it's a portal for fun,
like fun.
I mean,
that's what you're getting out of it.
You like seeing the stupid shitty rights
and go,
oh my god.
And you correlate some of the time so
that he writes it.
Yeah,
it's 2:00 in the morning.
Is that interesting?
I don't want,
but that's the thing.
I don't know.
Again,
I get it.
I understand people,
you know,
people are excited to have a genuine
person who's not a politician in there
and you know,
there's some benefit to shake the system
up for sure and need some shaking,
but you know,
how much shaking is actually been done.
I don't want that.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I'd rather the president not spend as
much time watching tv or a tweeting,
um,
and working to try to accomplish
something major in the way of tax reform
or even the healthcare problem couldn't
lord,
we're not even to get that done.
I think there's also a real problem from
the top down when the commander in chief
likes to personally insult people.
I think when you do that,
you,
you make that kind of behavior not just
acceptable but standard.
yeah.
well it's like,
well,
with your kids and kids,
you know,
if they were probably more to the point,
it's like people we talked about the
fact that nobody can keep their yap
shot,
right?
So secrets get out there right now and
that's because we've created this
environment.
If it's okay for a former defense
secretary,
a former head of the cia or whatever,
when they get out to write a book,
right?
And they're getting paid millions of
dollars to write that book.
So you know,
they got to cough up something
interesting.
IF they do that over a period of time
and they've been doing that,
then people down below think,
well,
why the fuck yeah,
all sign the same agreements to keep her
yap shut,
but maybe it's okay.
So it starts at the top.
I think,
you know,
and it's just like with parenting,
I mean they got to see you do the things
that you tell them to do.
Otherwise kids are sharp enough to
think,
well you're not doing it right.
You know?
So I think it's,
I don't know where I was going with
that.
I tend to get,
I tend to get down the rabbit hole and
distracted.
This is a distracting subject because
it's really difficult to see how do we
get out of this?
Like,
well okay,
we've,
we've obviously got this guy who's
running the country is doing a lot of
things that people don't enjoy.
They don't like.
They see a lot of problems in it and
they don't see a,
a real light at the end of the tunnel.
It's like what's the best case scenario?
Is this guy going to get us in a fucking
war with North Korea?
So we realized like,
oh,
North Korea and us,
we know we're going to war now.
This could have been avoided.
We got to get rid of them.
I mean,
what's the worst case scenario that has
to happen where we can survive as a
country but still just recover from
this.
The North Korea thing is,
is uh,
is kind of frustrating in a sense,
right?
Because nobody should be out there
thinking that.
And I'm sure you know,
very few do that somehow.
We got to that point with North Korea
because president trump is president,
right?
We got to this point when North Korea,
because we kicked the can down the road
for two and a half decades of failed
foreign policy with North Korea and in
part with China.
And so they've been very clear about
what they wanted to do and now they've
gotten to that point where they've
created the weapons program and the
ballistic missile program that they want
or that they are close to having.
And you knoW,
when you get to that point,
you naturally lose some of your options,
you know,
so the decision tree gets smaller and
trump happens to be the president in
office now when North Korea reaches that
stage and North Korea is pretty
consistent in the way that they've been
behaving,
you know,
they're always doing the same thing.
They throw their teddy out of the cot
when they get upset and they want some
attention where they feel they can get
something out of it.
Typically they do get something or China
get something that then they're willing
to reign them in
to some degree,
um,
in just like,
you know,
trump could well Be the guy sitting in
an office where Iran gets to that point
because anybody who thinks Iran is not
spinning the centrifuges and continuing
to work on their weapons capabilities
is,
is somewhat insane.
I mean that,
there is no,
uh,
john kerry said the whole Iran deal was
based on verification,
you know,
on.
And we don't have verification.
We don't have,
we don't,
we haven't gotten access still to some
facilities that we would need to see.
We signed off with the previous
administration,
signed off on a,
on a study or a,
an assessment basically just to get the
deal done because the iranians insisted
that that investigation into their
capabilities at one of their military
sites come to a close.
It wasn't like we suddenly got answers
and we were satisfied tHat there was no.
And we just,
okay,
that was part of the deal.
So we'll end that investigation,
but we don't have that verification.
so trump could do my point being trump
could just be sitting in that seat,
uh,
when North Korea gets where they are
when Iran possibly,
you know,
because that could happen sooner rather
than later.
And then,
yeah.
Then you'd like to think that the person
in that position will be rational.
Yes.
Little more reasoned.
I read an article today that is saying
that,
that him saying all that crazy shit
about fire and fury at the world has
ever seen,
might've actually Been what he needed to
say.
When you're dealing with someone like
North Korea.
And I mean,
it was obviously an opinion piece,
but the argument was that when you're
dealing with someone does as fucked up
as kim jong,
you're probably better off having
someone as crazy as trump as president
who's going to say some ridiculous shit
like that.
So this guy goes,
all right,
this guy's just as nuts as me.
Does that mean that there could be.
And frankly,
those messages that he's,
he does his things that he said were
probably more important in terms of how
China received them.
Then how North Korea received them,
and honestly,
20 plus years of,
of measure diplomatic language and
restrained talk didn't really do
anything.
It just kicked the can down the road.
So yeah,
maybe,
maybe a different approach in a measured
fashion.
But the problem is because of their sort
of the perceived chaos,
nobody has the confidence to believe
that he's doing it in a disciplined,
reasoned way.
So they don't look at it and go,
yeah,
he's saying that's a message he's
sending it.
Just looked at it and go,
you just go blasting off another tweet
up,
Scott Adams.
Scott adams is the only one that
believes this is some large,
clever masterplan.
We mIss scott as a dilbert.
dilbert.
Yeah.
I know about that.
Scott adams,
like the most rational,
logical,
intelligent trump supporter that's ever
lived and he's not really a trump
support.
Support.
Didn't vote for trump because he talks
about these things.
He doesn't want to vote for president
because he doesn't want to have a stake
in the game,
but he believes that trump is a master
persuader and that everything he's doing
is because of the art of persuasion.
It's very interesting.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I'd falls apart under scrutiny.
Kind of fell apart with his art.
These,
these arguments with a podcast with sam
harris is pretty fascinating.
No,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's.
I can see where people.
I've heard that from trump supporters
when they talk about how he's.
Everything's measured.
Everything in his own way.
His is,
is actually disciplined because I've
said numerous times that I think they
lacked discipline and they said,
no,
no.
Actually this is all part of the plan.
I'm thinking it doesn't look like it's
part of the plan because you've got
other people that are in those senior
positions that seem to be scrambling to
catch up to the plan.
And if it was part of the plan,
he'd like to think it was,
you know,
it was,
it was part of a conversation amongst
the,
uh,
the cabinet.
But anyway,
uh,
yeah,
so I,
I don't think,
you know,
I don't think we're.
Missiles aren't going to be flying
between us and North Korea.
I think China may actually see at this
stage of the game,
um,
they may see that they need to,
uh,
affect the different mindset for North
Korea and they may be doing that and
part of it may be,
again,
not necessarily because it was a reason
to thought out plan,
but trump's comments about the trade
imbalance with China.
If the chinese legitimately thought that
we were going to put that under the
microscope and maybe attack them on the
trade imbalance in a serious way,
then maybe they look at that and go,
okay,
well we can get them to back off.
Then.
Yes,
we're willing to extend ourselves and
actually listened to the sanctions and
take part in the sanctions and exert
some additional pressure on North Korea
that maybe they weren't in the past
because China always accidents own best
interest and so they're,
they're looking for something,
what are we going to get out of this?
And maybe so maybe that's,
you know,
in.
Anyway,
in the meantime it seems to have
resolved itself to some degree,
but I,
I do worry that,
you know,
once again,
and we're Just kicking it down the road,
you know,
I mean until there's something,
some sea change where,
you know,
maybe somehow we can affect a unified,
uh,
Korea with china's assistance.
It's going to have to be with their
assistants and blessing obviously a or
something along those lines to get
actual deterrence,
you know,
off the table and more of a removal of
the nuclear threat.
you know,
we're just going to be doing this same
conversation in another couple of years
when they rattle the cage again and we
have to figure out how to resolve it.
And the further you go down the road and
the better their capabilities get,
the fewer options you have.
So.
Well mike,
I'm sufficiently depressed.
Thank you very much.
My job.
Will this meet up again at six months if
the shit hits the fan?
So you know,
it's always fun talking to you about
your insight.
I went off on a tangent there,
don't we both did.
That's part of the program.
cool man.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right fOlks.
We'll see you soon.
Bye.